Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische,
Meine Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 73. Ausgabe.
In der Reihe rund um die Sterne das ganze wie immer mit Unterstützung der Stiftung Planetarium Berlin.
Unten ja heute geht's tatsächlich mal mehr in ein Randgebiet der Raumfahrt oder sagen wir mal ändern,
Kerngebiet der Erforschung des Weltalls und trotzdem gehen wir gar nicht so weit über die Orbitz hinaus sondern richtig in die,
jadewein konkret wollen wir heute sprechen über,
den Ice Cube ein ganz spezielles Forschungsprojekt und dazu begrüße ich zunächst einmal in meinem Gesprächspartner für mich Marcel Marcel Uslar.
Blue Marcel du bist dumm.
Wissenschaftler das kann man sagen ne konkreter bist du Doktorand und wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter beim DC.
Mit dem tollen mit der tollen auf Abkürzung Auflösung deutsches elektronen-synchrotron.
Wie oft spricht man das komplett aus und wie oft benutzt hat die Abkürzung.
Der Welten ich glaube meistens nimmt man tatsächlich die Abkürzung.
Ja weil ich schon ganz gut bekannt ist mein SD sie ist durchaus etabliert trotzdem was steckt in den Namen drin.
Google bring mich steigt in den Armen die sie wieder Name Synchrotron sagt irgendwie,
der beginnen als Teilchenbeschleuniger also ein Synchrotron ist eine Art von Teilchenbeschleuniger der in Hamburg an die sie gebaut wurde und da steckt natürlich im Namen drinnen da stecken die Wurzeln des Instituts.
Mittlerweile machen wir natürlich deutlich mehr wir sind also auch an Zeiten aktiv da komme ich her von dem Daisy und dann machen wir vor allen Dingen auch Astroteilchenphysik.
Was ist dass das Gebiet in dem ich auch tätig bin.
Das heißt da hast du dich mal passend ausbilden lassen was muss man da studieren.
Genauer man fängt mit dem Physikstudium an und dann irgendwann wird man sich so ein bisschen in Richtung Astrophysik oder Teilchenphysik.
Spezialisieren und gegebenenfalls eben diese Mischung finden also bei mir war es so ich habe interessiert mit großem Interesse Astronomie angefangen und bin dann irgendwann in die Teilchenphysik und irgendein habe ich festgestellt dass es dazwischen eine Schnittstelle gibt die ganz spannend ist und dann.
Rutschmann aquadesign.
Warum hast du mir sowas hatte ich da gerufen.
Astronomie hat mich irgendwie schon immer so ein bisschen interessiert und dann fängt man so im ersten Semester Physik Studium das ist noch relativ grundlegend und dann Feldmann plötzlich fest es gibt so Vorlesungen die sich mit Astrologie beschäftigen und die sind interessant und,
genau da habe ich dann einfach mal reingehört.
Also reingerutscht.
Also das war dann schon eine Weile aber Astronomie ist einfach nur also fand ich damals eine spannende Sache genommen beschäftigt sich soeben mit den Fragen was was gibt es im Universum wie kann man das beobachten.
Und dann eben in Richtung Astroteilchenphysik nach ein paar Jahren.
Weil die Astroteilchenphysik noch mal eine ganz andere Herangehensweise an diese Frage hat also während die klassische Astronomie sich darauf beschränkt.
Die die die die Himmelskörper die wir im Universum beobachten mit elektromagnetischen Wellen zu beobachten das heißt klassischerweise Teleskope so fing es an Mann hat es im Licht im sichtbaren Licht angeschaut,
bis hin dann irgendwann zu wirklich ausgefallenen Teleskopen Radioteleskope die im Radioastronomie machen oder halt auch noch hochenergetische Teleskope wie.
Röntgen oder Gammastrahlung Teleskop aber Aldi haben gemeinsam dass sie eben in dem elektromagnetischen,
Wellenlängenbereiche dass die elektromagnetische Wellen beobachten und die Astroteilchenphysik hat eine ganz andere Herangehensweise die versucht eben Astronomie zu betreiben mit Teilchen also mit Materie,
Ding aus dem wir auch bestehen wie beispielsweise Protonen und ebendieser Neutrinos wo wir sicherlich noch drauf zu sprechen kommen als ganz spezielle Teilchen Jungs interessieren.
Und welche Rolle spielt das die Lieder jetzt konkret.
Das Dessert hatte Glauben in Deutschland auf jeden Fall eine führende Rolle in in vielen Astroteilchenphysik Exkrementen klar Icepeak natürlich worüber heute reden aber auch in Gammastrahlung Sex Momenten z.b. also wirklich hochenergetische,
hochenergetisches Licht mehr oder weniger und dort betreibt sie also ist involviert bei einigen Teleskopen,
die auf der ganzen Welt verteilt sind und das desinas.de sie macht natürlich noch viel mehr also wir haben also in Zeuthen haben wir auch noch Gruppen die in der theoretischen Astroteilchenphysik arbeiten in der,
also Missbrauch Mittel mit Licht arbeiten und in Hamburg natürliche Teilchenphysik.
Jetzt,
ist das immer so also wenn man sich mit anderen Leuten sogar Wissenschaft unterhält und gerade war es von Omi da so Sternen alles was ich bewegt das lässt sich ja ganz gut nachvollziehen und das Atom,
habe ich auch schon mal jeder gehört und woraus dazu besteht aber so die Teilchen.
Ist irgendwie noch mal so eine Welt wo glaube ich sodass common knowledge ganz gut aussteigt was sind die Erfahrung wird wahrscheinlich auch schon gemacht hat.
Das richtig ja.
Dass er jetzt hier letztlich um Neutrinos geht was muss man denn verstanden haben um das überhaupt erstmal nachvollziehen zu können.
Also bei den Teilchen ist glaube ich eine wichtige Sache die man verstehen muss dass wir von von Elementarteilchen reden was heißt das sind unserem Verständnis und dem aktuellen Verständnis nach Zeichen die nicht irgendwie weiter aus anderen Teilen zusammengesetzt sind,
also Anton an der Stelle haben wir haben festgestellt dass es Naturgefahren festgestellt Atom besteht aus einem Kern wo Protonen Neutronen drin sind und Aussenhülle wo er sich Elektronen befinden das ist in der Regel noch das was man in der Schule auch soll,
und dann irgendwann mal festgestellt der Atomkern besteht auch noch aus irgendwas also aus dem Protonen Neutronen und die wiederum bestehen auch noch mal aus etwas was sich Korks nennt und da hört dann sozusagen unser grundlegendes unser unser Wissen auf also wir,
glauben aktuell nicht dass es dass diese auch normales irgendetwas zusammengesetzt sind und dann spricht man von Elementarteilchen.
Das hat die Quarks die quasi Protonen und Neutronen ausmachen die Rigips glaube ich sechs richtig und diesen dann wiederum Ost Elementarteilchen zusammengesetzt und direktes viele.
Nein Elementarteilchen wären in dem Fall die Crocs C6 Crocs genau und das Elektron würde auch als Elementarteilchen zählen weil nach jetzigem Stand ist es auch nicht weiter auflösbare besteht auch nicht genau richtig.
Steht auch nur auf dich selbst was heißt eigentlich gibt es nur die Quark.
Es gibt auch noch ein paar andere Sachen die in einem Kern sozusagen wechselt also sind auch die Blumen die gehören auch dazu das sind so wechselwirkungsteilchen die würde man noch dazu zählen aber im Wesentlichen sind sind es die Quarks aus dem,
die unsere Materie besteht.
Aber wo kommt denn diese also welche Form von Beobachtung konnte denn davon schon gemacht worden werden also was was könnte gesehen werden.
Er gesehen wird im Wesentlichen also das mach mal mit Teilchenbeschleunigern die Teilchenbeschleuniger sind eigentlich so was die Mikroskope,
also es fängt fängt im Prinzip damit an wir wollen etwas sehr kleines sehen da könnte man z.b. Lichtmikroskop nehmen aber irgendwann ist die Auflösungsgrenze von dem Lichtmikroskop erreicht das heißt man kann sich vielleicht noch ein H,
auf dem auf dem Lichtmikroskop angucken aber wenn etwas sehr viel kleiner wird können wir mit Licht nicht mehr beobachten.
Unten Teilchenbeschleuniger ist eigentlich sowas wie ein sehr sehr teures Mikroskop beschissen da irgendwelche Zeichen die wir kennen aufeinander beispielsweise Elektronen oder Elektron Positron dass wir das.
Positiver Antiteilchen von einem Elektron die schießt man irgendwie aufeinander und dann wechselwirken die miteinander und dann kommt da irgendwas raus,
das was da rauskommt so sekundär Teilchen würden sagen das ist etwas was wir uns genau angucken und auf,
Basis dessen was wir da beobachten können wir dann zurück schließen was da vermutlich passiert ist in diesem in dieser in dieser Wechselwirkung und so kommt man,
auf dieses komplette Standardmodell der Teilchenphysik wo man dann lernt woraus besteht das eigentlich alles dass es diese 6 Quarks im gibt dass es auch noch andere Bestandteile dieses dieses dieses Modell gibt.
Und das Lernen will sozusagen aus diesem Teilchenbeschleuniger Exponenten.
Erkennt das ja vor allem vom Centro wo das.
Größe die Busse Installation derzeit steht aber das ist ja nicht der einzige beständige es gibt halt den vom DESY und was ich around the world.
Bayreuth.
Ganze Weile her.
Das heißt diese Teilchenbeschleuniger sind sind das moderne Teleskop um quasi in das kleinste zu schauen was man überhaupt noch,
sehen kann und man sieht es nicht darf ich dass man es einfach so fotografiert sondern man kann eigentlich nur darauf schließen dass es existiert wenn man beobachtet wird,
reagiert indem Fall halt reagiert wenn es irgendwie möglich ist katastrophal Auflösung sowieso Crashtest macht.
Genau genau.
Und es richtig verstanden habe ist so quasi die die Ablenkung dieses Crasher eigenes ist der der einzelnen Teile die sich da Freischießen die lassen einen Schluss darauf zu was ist denn ist.
Genau also da kommen ganz also ganz viele Sachen spielen damit damit rein die Ablenkung ist eine Sache da kann man beispielsweise herausfinden welche Teilchen das sind die dort gerade rauskommen aus diesem Wechselwirkungsprozesse aber die rechte Seite die Experimente die einem Teilchenbeschleuniger am CERN sind,
die Messe natürlich noch ganz andere Dinge als im Essen auch wie viel Energie beispielsweise ein einzelnes Teilchen aus diesem ganzen wüstenteichen die da rauskommt hat uns das natürlich ganz wichtig,
um um diese Prozesse zu verstehen und um dann auch am Ende zu sagen das was da passiert ist das können wir so zu sagen damit messen also was für Teilchen das sind wie viel Energie sie haben,
und durchaus auch welche welche Krümmung sie beispielsweise hätten also daraus kann man beispielsweise auch was ablesen.
Und was ist jetzt die Erkenntnisse also ich meine auf der einen Seite lasse.
Dass die Quarks und der endet ist aber es gibt auch noch zahlreiche tausend andere Bezeichnung für Teilchen ohne Ende die am laufenden Meter entdeckt werden also wie verhält sich das jetzt zueinander.
Das sind im Prinzip die die Erde gebundene Zustände von diesem Crocs also die Kork sind am Ende die die die Elementarteilchen die Bestandteile dieser Teilchen aber man spricht ja tatsächlich auch von diesem teilchenzoo also man findet eine ganze Reihe verschiedener Teilchen,
die aber alle aus diesen zusammengesetzt sind,
und das ist das was du gerade meinst also man findet immer mal wieder neue Teilchen man spricht von sogenannten Resonanzen die sind in der Regel existieren die kurz und zerfallen dann wieder irgendwelche anderen Teilchen und die sind aber alle aus diesem Quarks zusammengesetzt und das ist sozusagen das interessante dieses Modells,
was über Jahrzehnte entwickelt wurde das man tatsächlich so dass man Vorhersagen treffen kann und auch diese,
Resonanzen diese Teilchen entdeckt werden damit erklären kann im Prinzip mit diesen 6 Bausteinen und natürlich den Kräften die dazu kommt und die die Austauschteilchen die auch dazu gehört.
Was sind die Protonen und Neutronen quasi nur so ganz spezielle super mega stabile Kombination von den Quarks.
Genau richtig das sind eigentlich die stabilen,
wenn ich sogar die Eier die einzigen stabilen also das ist das woraus wir bestehen du und ich der Tisch alles um uns herum besteht irgendwas Protonen Neutronen und das sind die Dinge die stabil sind Neutronen sind noch mal Spezialfall die können wenn sie alleine sind zerfallen die auch,
sind also auch instabil aber in so einer Proton und Elektron nicht oder sozusagen der Grund warum wir überhaupt existieren,
weil wir aus diesen 2013 stabilen Teilchen bestehen während es hunderte weitere gibt die dies natürlich eigentlich gar nicht gibt weil sie eben wieder zerfallen.
Hat man schon verstanden warum die eigentlich die einzigen sind die nicht wieder zerfallen.
Nein ich würde sagen das hat man noch nicht verstanden also es gibt tatsächlich suchen die Expedition da fällt das Brot dann nicht vielleicht doch.
Und es kann durchaus sein dass es instabil ist nur damit etwas zerfällt muss es ein leichteres Teilchen geben dass es da fallen kann und auch wenn das Elektron leichter ist als das Proton.
Bestimmt der Naturgesetze zumindest scheint die zugeben dass das sozusagen verbietet und.
Eine eine Schlussfolgerung jemand raus treffen kann ist das wenn das Proton beispielsweise instabil wäre dass die Halbwertszeit aber deutlich länger sein muss als das Alter des Universums.
Weil man so kann das noch nicht hat beobachten können dass er mal irgendwas zerfällt und diese Quarks für sich genommen also können die auch einfach nur für sich existieren oder existieren sie eigentlich immer nur in Kombination mit.
Sie existieren nur in Kombination sie kann nicht alleine existieren.
So aber wenn das Deck Stück sind dann ist ja quasi die möglichen Kombinationen auch auch endlich oder sind nicht immer nur zwei oder könnt ihr auch beliebig viele zusammenhängen.
Genau alles gibt unter es gibt von Grundherr gibt es zwei unterschiedliche Typen einmal die Typen die aus drei Quarks aufgebaut sind und einmal die aus zwei VOX aufgebaut sind darin können sich unterscheiden sie können sich in ihrer Art also es gibt quarks.de,
tragen sozusagen unterschiedliche Eigenschaften wenn das in der Physik Farbe weil uns kein besserer Name dafür eingefallen ist,
und die können unterschiedlichen Kombinationen auftreten und die können auch in unterschiedlichen anregungszustände,
auftreten das ein bisschen wie beim Atom das hat man vielleicht mal gelernt dass ein Elektron irgendwie so Bahnen hat und dass ein Elektron auf eine höhere Bahn springen kann und dann wieder zurück das ist eine anregungszustand den gibt es auch,
also sagen bei diesem Quarks da kommen nur zeigen am Ende eine Menge Menge Eigenschaften zusammen sodass die verschiedene Teilchen die sie bilden sich tatsächlich auch unterscheiden an ihren Eigenschaften bei Zusage Einladung.
Oder 1 Pin das wäre sozusagen sowas wie ein Eigendrehimpuls sich Klasse gesprochen die die Teilchen um sich selbst drehen.
Genau oder halt in ihrer Eigenschaft welche Masse sie haben oder welche Lebensdauer sie haben also wann wie schnell sie zerfallen da unterscheiden sich die Teilchen sehr stark voneinander.
Seit wann ist denn das so klar dass diese Quark Welt eigentlich das ist was alles zusammen rührt.
Das eine gute Frage also ich glaube klar es ist vieles nicht also ist er,
es entwickelt sich immer weiter und es gibt auch also dieses diese Standardmodell der Teilchenphysik ist natürlich schon eine phänomenale Errungenschaft weil es einfach enorm viel erklären gleichzeitig erklären können und auch enorm viele vorhersagen richtig getroffen hat aber es gibt Begrenzung das wissen wir,
7 Paar Limitierung beispielsweise weil wir was miteinander sprechen während der Teilchen Standardmodell der Teilchenphysik sagt eigentlich voraus dass das Neutrino keine Masse haben dürfte also das ist,
masselos ist und sich dementsprechend genauso wie Licht mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen würde Andreas Moment haben aber gezeigt dass das noch drin oder was haben muss das heißt hier gibt es so eine Begrenzung,
Gültigkeit dieses Standardmodell der Teilchenphysik das heißt klar ist,
sozusagen schwierig aber dass wir sind natürlich sehr sicher dass das dass die die Teilchen die beobachten aus diesem Quarks bestehen und das ist schon seit ein paar Jahrzehnten klar würde würde ich sagen.
Was für Eigenschaften als ist hast du ja schon paar genannt Masse Spinnen und was war das erste noch gleich genau die Ladung gibt es noch weitere relevante.
Eigenschaften die man jetzt bei solchen Teilchen messen kann.
Im Wesentlichen natürlich was ist weiter also Alvor Ausrüster zusammengesetztes woraus besteht,
und dann ist am Ende tatsächlich mit am wichtigsten wenn es darum geht diese Teilchen zu detektieren nachzuweisen wie lange leben sie wie lange ist die Lebensdauer und worunter fallen sie,
weil Aldi so viele Dateien lassen sich das sächlich nur durch diese Sekundärprodukte nachweisen also wenn sie irgendwann sie existieren existiert nur von kurzer Moment der zerfallen sie produziert und welche anderen Teilchen das sind meistens die Diva auch nachweisen das funktioniert bei Ice Cube und mit den Neutrinos genauso und deswegen ist es wichtig zu wissen wohin woran sie zerfallen.
Ja du hast die allermeisten Zustände sind extrem temporär und so richtig dauerhaft sind eigentlich nur die Protonen und die Neutronen und.
Und die Elektronen und alles andere ist geht irgendwie ineinander über.
Mehr oder weniger liegt es natürlich auch richtig Lichterfeld am Ende auch nicht aber Licht kann natürlich absorbiert werden gestreut werden also.
Aber was du da. Weil liest.
Unsere allgemeinen Wahrnehmung immer sowas was neben einem anderen steht zu die Welten angeblich die Felder drauf du Arbeit natürlich ist es auch teil.
Muss es ja dann zwangsläufig auch Teil dieses Teilchen so sein weil nichts ist nicht Teil dieses Zoos was ist dann.
Nicht also setzt sich das dann auch aus Quarks zusammen.
Nein also liegt es etwas vollkommen eigenständiges und in diesen in dieses Modell passt es rein als sogenanntes Austauschteilchen das heißt darunter versteht man am Ende ein Jahr eine Form von.
Durch Australien als man spricht vom Photon also sozusagen ein also das ist wenn wenn Licht sozusagen als,
mehr weniger als Zeichen Auftritt auch wenn es ganz ist weil es keine Masse hat dann passt das sozusagen als Austauschteilchen daran das heißt immer wenn es um die.
Wenn es um die elektromagnetische Kraft geht also beispielsweise zwei geladene Teilchen miteinander wechselwirken kennen wir aus der Schule negativ und negativ geladen stoßen sich ab,
dieses abstoßen würde man dann sozusagen schreiben als da wird ein Lichtteilchen ausgetauscht,
das machen wir das wird so sozusagen in die Hände nehmen können an quantenmechanischen Experimenten gemacht also immer wenn es darum geht das Teilchen miteinander wechselwirken irgendwas Neues passiert dann ist das,
Lichtteilchen das Photon es relevant dafür dass diese Wechselwirkungen mit dass diese Wechselwirkung passiert.
Und weiß man woraus sich dieses Teilchen auch zusammensetzt.
Aus aus Licht als elektromagnetische Wellen dass das Licht sind elektromagnetische Wellen das und am Ende ja wie soll man sagen Felder sowieso Vivi Radio auch für sichtbares Licht die sich die sich ausbreiten.
Also ist das Licht dann nicht wirklich Teil des teilchenzoo.
Nicht das teilchenzoo es ist gehört zu den Austauschteilchen.
Was ist noch mal separat.
Da das mitgenommen also man unterscheidet grundsätzlich die Teilchen die Elementarteilchen die die sozusagen die die die Konstituenten,
dieses diese anderen Teilchen sind auf den Süßkram setzen und dann dazu die aus das Teil Austauschteilchen,
oder gehören auch andere dazu daran dass das Lichtzeichen das Foto an ist das Austauschteilchen der elektromagnetischen Kraft es gibt aber noch die Gravitationskraft die starke Kraft und die schwache Kraft und dort gibt es jeweils andere Austauschteilchen.
Das heißt diese aus und ist das nur ein Modell.
Dieser Begriff Austauschteilchen damit das sozusagen diese Betrachtungsweise reinpasst oder kann man das auch.
Wirklich alles dagegen dann Teilchen rein und raus und setzen sich vor zu wie sich Elektronen auch bei Strom austauschen.
Ja ja ist eine schwierige Frage also natürlich ist es Modell aber andererseits wissen wir dass das gibt also du siehst mich gerade ich sehe dich gerade das liegt daran dass das Licht dass ich das Licht zwischen uns ausbreitet also natürlich ist es real.
Jana Filipstad.
Aber natürlich die artundweise wie es beschrieben wird gerade in diesem quantenmechanischen Prozessen das ist natürlich Modell aber man muss halt sagen Modell das natürlich sehr sehr gut funktioniert und sehr gut beschreibt was da passiert und was da am Ende rauskommt was also vorhersagen trifft die man experimentell überprüfen kann.
Das heißt man kann sagen auch alle alle vier Grundkräfte der Natur sind quasi lass oder lassen sich zumindest beschreiben als Austauschteilchen.
Genau mit Ausnahme der Gravitation das ist doch mal bisschen schwieriger und noch aktives Forschungsfeld das würden wir jetzt nicht da nicht dazu zählen.
Okay aber ich starke Kernkraft die schwache Kernkraft und Elektromagnetismus die fallen darunter ok und damit auch das Licht und Gravitation das unbekannte Wesen.
Ja das ist ein etwas schwieriges Thema.
Dexter dass es noch unverstanden ist.
Nein er nicht im Wesentlichen unverstanden aber die Gravitationskraft ist einfach so wahnsinnig viel schwächer als die anderen drei Kräfte dass es sozusagen immer schwierig ist nachzuweisen.
Okay aber man geht schon davon aus dass es eigentlich in dasselbe Modell passen müsste.
Es sollte dasselbe Modell passen alle Teilchen die irgendwie miteinander wechselwirken haben in der Regel auch eine Masse.
Und dementsprechend sollte diese Kraft halt auch eine Rolle spielen nur ist sie halt sehr sehr viel kleiner.
Das heißt bevor er sozusagen Gravitationskraft zwischen zwei von mir das Elektron eine Rolle spielt ist aber die Coulombkraft also die elektromagnetische Kraft ist einfach so viel stärker als die Gravitation.
Die Gravitationskraft ist natürlich relevant für alles was groß ist also dass wir sagen ich von der Erde wegfliegen liegt daran dass die Erde noch mal eine große Masse hat uns festhält.
Ja das kann man ja täglich spüren.
Zum Glück ein Toast auf die Gravitation so ist muss er trotzdem noch mal einen Begriff noch mal hinterfragen zumal er ja jetzt bei denen Neutrinos auch noch eine Rolle spielt.
Das ist das Ding mit der Masse weil ich habe verstanden dass man jetzt quasi ja jüngst erst im CERN,
mit dem Higgs-Boson quasi so einen letzten Baustein einer lange existierenden Theorie gefunden hat der quasi jetzt dieses Phänomen,
Masse erklärt was sind das.
Ja
Oder bist du bist schon mal richtig aufgenommen so aber was.
Muss man sich jetzt unter Masse konkret vorstellen gerade vor dem Hintergrund dass manche Dinge die sie nicht haben.
Irgendwie was ist eine schwierige Frage ich glaube sie auch eine konzeptionelle Frage am Ende weil du das Higgs-Boson die 6 Entdeckung ansprichst in in,
Dokumente in dem Konzept geht es darum dass es ein Feld gibt,
einen also etwas also ich dringend das im gesamten Universum dass das Higgs Feld heißt und das Licht Teilchen am Ende sagen durch dieses Feld Durchbewegen so ein bisschen wie als würde man,
Stadt durch Wasser durch Sirup gehen also man hat irgendwie ein bisschen mehr Widerstand sozusagen und dass die artundweise dass sie ein solches Teilchen mit diesem Higgs-Feld wechselwirkt dass das sozusagen eine Beschreibung der Masse ist,
ich persönlich denke mir im Alltag eher Masse als dass die das auch empfinden etwas ist schwer etwas hat sozusagen viel in Sicht,
und wird deswegen von der Erde stärker angezogen und ich finde dass der Begriff durchaus auch,
also dass man sich den auch in indem worüber wir reden vor ich gut vorstellen kann dass Teiche miteinander sozusagen die teilnehmender wechselwirken haben einfach sind einfach mehr oder weniger schwer.
Unter uns ist das sozusagen insbesondere deswegen relevant das ein schweres Teilchen,
und viele viele andere Teilchen zerfallen kann je leichter ein Teilchen ist desto weniger andere leistet heißen gibt es in dass es davon kann das heißt da ist es sozusagen wichtig,
da wo wir sozusagen am Ende unsere Wissenschaft mit der Neutrinos rummachen neutrinophysik.
Okay aber so man könnte auch sich das jetzt mal so klar machen dass Masse eine Eigenschaft ist die letztlich bedeutet das.
Es in der Gesamtmenge der Teilchen Dinge gibt mit dem man dann hinter agiert wo Sachen ohne Masse nicht mit interagieren also manche werden quasi gebremst in diesem Sirup und manche interessiert das einfach überhaupt nicht.
Ja ich denke man könnte es so sagen.
Wie wichtig ist eigentlich für die Masse auch sozusagen wie wie schnell sich ein Teilchen bewegen kann wenn man ein Zeichen jetzt beschleunigt im Energie zuführt,
dann wird natürlich ein Teilchen was sehr leichtes sehr viel schneller werden oder sehr viel schneller beschleunigt werden können dann gegen ein Teilchen was sehr schwer ist im Bett länger brauchen genauso wie ein Sportwagen schneller beschleunigt als ein LKW,
ich glaube vor dem Hintergrund ist es sozusagen bisschen ein bisschen wichtiger zu verstehen dass die die eigentliche Wechselwirkung von den Teilchen die haben eigentlich nichts mit der Masse am Ende wirklich zu tun.
Weil die die Wechselwirkung passiert eben durch diese anderen drei Kräfte die die viel relevanter sind.
Aber die Masse hat natürlich ist natürlich wichtig in dem Sinne sozusagen wie viel Energie auch insgesamt zur Verfügung steht und irgendwelche anderen Teilchen zu erzeugen.
Also das heißt.
Und bei dem Beispiel mit dem LKW zu bleiben LKW hat einfach auch bei einer geringeren Geschwindigkeit am Ende deutlich viel mehr Energie wenn es jetzt beispielsweise gegen Baum fahren würde also ein Sportwagen und das ist in der Teilchenphysik ähnlich die massereicher,
ein Teilchen ist also je schwerer es ist desto mehr kann man sozusagen auch daraus machen wenn man wenn man das auf eine entsprechende Energie beschleunigen würde.
Wie kann man wieder etwas absurde Vergleiche noch dieses schöne psychologische Experiment wo man so spielen Kinder sieht die sich Bälle zuwerfen und dann kriegst du die Aufgabe mit der achte mal drauf wie oft der grüne Ball und der rote Ball hin und her geht so mein Schatz ich das irgendwie an,
und am Schluss wird man halt gefragt mehr und hast du auch den Affen gesehen so ja dann halt im hintergrund Obi durchgehend so und das war sozusagen etwas nicht,
dadurch bewegt man ihm aber überhaupt gar keine Aufmerksamkeit schenkt weil man eben nicht mit ihm interagieren oder das.
Hatte mich so ein bisschen außer dieses Bild von das ist zwar irgendwie da aber das will halt niemand was von ihm.
Ja ja kann man kann man durchaus genau kann man sich auch so beschreiben.
Okay ich will jetzt auch gar nicht zu sehr die komplette Teilchenphysik ja aufarbeiten aber ich denke dass ihn zu fragen die immer wieder aufkommen.
Jetzt gibt's.
Diese Neutrinos das erscheint mir ja auch so ein bisschen so die heimlichen Superstars zu sein.
Man hört immer wieder mal davon letztlich ist dass dir jetzt nur ein,
Teilchen von vielen also eine Quark Kombination von zwei oder drei Quarks wie alle anderen auch.
Nein also das Neutrino ist auch wieder ein Elementarteilchen steht für sich besteht aus nichts anderem keine Quark.
Keine Quarks im gibt's da noch andere Kandidaten weil jetzt hatte ich mich gerade drauf eingefahren das alles irgendwie Quark sind.
Nein alle alle großen Teilchen sind zusammengesetzt aus Quarks aber die Elementarteilchen stehen alle für sich alle mentata ich habe noch mit dir chords,
elektronischen Elementarteilchen dann gibt es noch die sozialen die schweren schweren Geschwister vom Elektron ist ein heißt Mühe und das andere ist auf,
das ist so außen auch Elementarteilchen die sind aber die sind installieren deswegen kommen sie sozusagen in der Natur ja begrenzt vor und dann weiteres Elementarteilchen wäre das neue wären die drei Neutrinos ausgebreiteten.
Aber das ist das genau das Neutrino ist auch ein Elementarteilchen.
Okay also gib doch noch mehr.
Quarks Elektron Myon Tau und Neutrinos und dann noch mal 3 und dann ist auch schon Schluss oder kommt er noch mal eine Tür.
Die Austauschteilchen zählt auch dazu.
Ah okay gut nelly hat Mercedes schon mal aber dann können wir das jetzt mal so langsam gruppiert sag mal ist wichtig dass ordentlich aufteilen zu können gut verstehe was macht jetzt.
Vielleicht kannst ja auch noch mal was zu Möhren untersagen weil jetzt haben ja nicht mehr so viele was was sind das für Freunde.
Also das sind am Ende also auch Elementarteilchen das heißt sie bestehen aus keinen weiteren anderen Teilchen.
Das Möhren ist denn sowas wie ein schweres Electrum das hat also alles Elektronen ist ja negativ geladen müssen wir uns auch eine negative Ladung wobei auch alle eine positive Ladung haben können wenn man über Antimaterie spricht,
aber es ist gerade einfach nur ein schweres Elektronen und das ist instabiles zerfällt also einer gewissen Zeit und das Tao ist sowas wie ein schweres mühren das ist also auch normal noch schwereres.
Geschwister Zeichen des Elektrons und das hat noch eine viel kürzere Lebenszeit das da fällt also noch viel viel schneller.
Okay aber sind beide so ein Elektron Kategorien.
Tierquartier.
KODi Neutrino stehen aber dann so ein bisschen neben einem anderen.
Genau die Neutrino sind insofern ganz Besonderes weil sie eben keine elektrische Ladung tragen das ist also immer ganz wichtig weil die die elektromagnetische Kraft ist nun mal eine sehr sehr starke Kraft.
Und alles was keine elektrische Ladung hat wechselwirkt im Prinzip nicht über diese Kraft das heißt das fällt raus.
Also Magnetismus interessiert das Neutrino einfach mal gar nicht.
Dann gibt es natürlich noch eine weitere starke Kraft das ist die die am Ende die Kerne zusammenhält dass die da heißt auch einfach starke Kraft das ist sozusagen die Kraft die zwischen Quarks wechselwirkt.
Und die sieht das Neutrino auch nicht das Neutrino hat also tatsächlich nur die Wechselwirkungen über eine relevante Kraft das ist die schwache Kraft.
Das ist die dem für radioaktive Zerfälle zuständig ist.
Und deswegen ist das Neutrino einfach und diese schwache Kraft ich meine deswegen heißt sie auch so dieses halt einfach sehr schwach und das heißt Neutrinos machen in der Regel nicht viel.
Sie sind also,
gibt es zuhauf also wir haben viele verschiedene Quellen die auf der Erde und im Universum aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein Neutrino was macht ist sehr gering das heißt man muss entweder der großen detector haben oder muss relativ lange warten wenn man versucht 1 zum essen.
Und auch dann genau das was ich eben auch schon sagte können wir Neutrino niemals direkt messen kann also nicht irgendwie uns ein Experiment aufbauen warten bis dann Neutrino durch 14 Tage naja ich habe es gesehen sondern nur über,
eine Wechselwirkung also über sekundär Teilchen wenn Neutrino irgendwie hängen bleibt und mit Hektor irgendwas macht und dabei ein Teilchen entsteht was wir sehen können was ist ein Elektron.
Aber nicht so das Neutrino so der der schwarze Affe der Teilchenphysik ist so dem man einfach nicht sieht.
Zeige sich keiner für Dich interessiert könnten doch auch eigentlich egal sein oder.
Nein wir interessieren uns natürlich sehr dafür gerade im Astronomie Bereich ist das Neutrino extrem spannend weil es ist ein bisschen Fluch und Segen zugleich einerseits wie ich gerade sagte macht das Neutrino natürlich nicht viel also es wechselwirkt nur sehr schwach,
aber andererseits ist das auch gerade gut weil dann kann man das Neutrino benutzen um sehr tief ins Universum reinzuschauen während andere Teilchen,
weiße Seite geladene Teilchen oder auch Licht auf dem Weg von irgendwo tief im Universum zu uns auf der Erde sehr großen großer Wahrscheinlichkeit haben vielleicht irgendwie abgelenkt zu werden oder absorbiert zu werden irgendwo fest zu stecken weil zwischen uns und,
Quelle natürlich eine Menge andere Sachen sein können dass schafft es sozusagen das Neutrino auf relativ geradem Weg,
durch zu fliegen bis zu uns das heißt wenn wir Neutrino sehen würden auf der Erde und wir könnten sagen das kommt aus der Richtung.
Dann können wir sozusagen am Ende auch sagen ok da wäre wahrscheinlich eine Quelle wo diese Neutrinos herkommen und das können wir das sächliche sehr sehr gut mit Neutrinos machen und nicht mit,
annateiche welche Seite geladenen Teilchen.
Gut schätzen dass ich die Frage,
wo kommen die her und warum ist das wichtig zu wissen woher die kommen ich meine zunächst einmal welches davon ausgegangen wenn es von Elementarteilchen ist dass das,
quasi ein Ergebnis des Urknalls war und seitdem fliegen die halt irgendwie um ungefragt und nicht reagieren zu durch die Gegend und das war's,
du sagst aber jetzt gibt Quellen die Dinge entstehen auch irgendwo was könnten das für Quellen sein.
Also nicht mal die Neutrinos vom Urknall die gibt es theoretisch auch die sind die sind 6 Monate sehr sehr schwer nachzuweisen alle anderen Neutrino Quellen,
also Neutrinos wurde ursprünglich mm normalen radioaktiven Zerfall nur nach dem Wetter Zufall entdeckt den können wir auf der Erde ohne Probleme beobachten das heißt nur trinus haben eine ganz natürliche Quelle nämlich natürliche Radioaktivität.
Was heißt in dem Moment wo jetzt Protonen und so durch die schwache Kernkraft einfach zerfallen.
Genau Neutron Neutron.
Die Neutronen in dem Moment werden vielleicht oder auf jeden Fall auf jeden Fall Neutrinos freigesetzt das weiß man.
Auf jeden Fall Neutrinos genau genau das weiß man genau was man schon sehr sehr lange.
Okay aber woher ich meine wie hat man die denn gesehen wenn die mit nichts reagieren oder war das nur so ein theoretisches Ding.
Zuerst was ein theoretisches Ding also ich glaube 19:30 Uhr oder so hatte Wolfgang Pauli das Neutrino einfach als als theoretisches Ding vorhergesagt,
der Grund war das man dass man von einem radioaktiven Zerfall wie z.b. wenn das Neutronenzahl fällt dann zerfällt ist in ein Proton und ein Elektron und in einer Trainer,
aber es muss drin und konnte man damals nicht dem Zerfall könnte man aber sehr wohl und dann gab es aus grundlegenden Überlegung der der Naturgesetze nämlich Energie und Impulserhaltung,
hatte man sozial durch die Beobachtung des Zerfalls sagen können ok hier muss ein drittes Zeichen sein also entweder stimmen unsere Naturgesetze nicht,
oder hier muss es ein drittes Teilchen geben was wir nicht sehen was aber Energie Weg trägt.
Zum Rest einer Division die sonst nicht aufgehen will.
Genau sozusagen ja richtig.
Und deswegen war sozusagen gibt es die theoretische Fundament für Neutrino geschaffen und es war deutlich später erstmals r53 das täglich diese das auch genau diese Reaktion auf nachgewiesen wurde und der Nachweis,
wiederum also es gibt viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten sowas nachzuweisen aber alle haben gemein dass wir das Neutrino niemals direkt messen sondern eben immer nur indirekt,
das ist also irgendwie Wechselwirkung von diesem Neutrino mit was anderem gibt das können Kerne sein das können auch was kann auch im Prinzip Elektronen sein und das sozusagen in dieser Reaktion wieder irgendwelche Teilchen entstehen die wir versuchen nachzuweisen.
Aber wie kann man eine Wechselwirkung mit Neutrino messen wenn dieses Neutrino sich eigentlich mit gar nichts wechselwirkt.
Ihm passt mir gar nichts also es ist eben sehr unwahrscheinlich was passiert natürlich sonst wirst du ja nicht dass es das gibt.
Na ja aber das geht dann nur wie die schwache Kernkraft sozusagen.
Über die schwache Kräfte.
Schwache Kraft hat nichts Verkehr Kraft schwache Kraft also das war es quasi für radioaktiven Zerfall sorgt aber wie kann das dann mit dem Neutrino zusammenkommen das heißt.
Also diese Kräfte wirken grundsätzlich quasi in beide Richtungen also das war sozusagen spontan passieren kann wenn ein Kern zerfällt was einfach normale Radioaktivität ist das kann man wenn man das ganze so ein bisschen provoziert also wenn man dem Energie zuführt kann man das auch genau in die umgekehrte Richtung machen.
Dann passiert junge kehrt Reaktion das heißt man würde in Neutrino mit einem mit einem Proton wechselwirken lassen hätte man am Ende Neutronen und Elektronen.
Asozial Radioaktivität rückwärts.
Genau sozusagen ja.
Und da können dann quasi Neutrinos indirekt nachgewiesen werden weil das nur mit denen geht also sind die Neutrinos quasi die Voraussetzung dafür.
Genau also es gibt bestimmte Reaktion die können eben nur über diese Neutrino stattfinden und.
Weil sonst keine Anderen Teilchen gibt die diese Eigenschaften so haben.
Genau sind was wir wissen dass es diese Reaktionen Einrichtung gibt also kann man die auch in der anderen Richtung nachweisen.
Ok aber das müsste ja dann eigentlich auch für die Neutronen auch gelten also wenn die sich mit der schwache Kernkraft auseinandersetzen dann müsste das ja auch dadurch durch die Teilchen die Neutronen ausmachen auch in die andere Richtung gehen können.
Versteht das falsch.
Nee also ich glaube also der der Punkt ist der das.
Dass wir von von von Teilchenphysik von Teilchenbeschleuniger von diesen Experimenten Wissen am Ende welche möglichen Wechselwirkungen es gibt.
Und dass sich über die Wechselwirkung diese Neutrinos und über diese Wechselwirkung eben bestimmte Reaktion voraussagen kann das heißt wenn man etwas misst irgendeinen Endprodukt.
Dann kann man am Ende sagen ok dieses Endprodukt kann aus folgenden Möglichkeiten kann das sozusagen entstehen und dann gibt es.
Reaktion wo eben nur das Neutrino in Frage kommt es gibt aber auch Reaktion wodurch das andere Kandidaten infrage käme das Neutrino hat aber immer sozusagen die Eigenschaft dass eine Reaktion sowas so quasi aus dem nichts passiert.
Das heißt wenn man sich beispielsweise also wurden die ersten Neutrino eigenes auch nach nachgewiesen in der sogenannten blasenkammer da wurde man,
es sowas wie Dampf drin und dieser Dampfer die Eigenschaft dass wenn da irgendwelche geladenen Teilchen durchblitzen dass sie sowas wie einen Kondensstreifen beim Flugzeug hinterlassen so eine Spur,
und dann konnte man beispielsweise sehen dass plötzlich aus dem Nichts Cinema 3 Spuren entstehen 3 geladene Teilchen die dort irgendwie hier irgendwie erzeugt wurden,
und dieses aus dem Nichts das eben das kann nur ein neutral geladenes Teilchen was sozusagen nicht wechselwirkt muss man diese Neutrinos die schleichen sich da ein die sieht man nicht direkt und sie müssen aber sozusagen Wechselwirkung erzeugen weil aus dem Nichts laut unserer Naturgesetzen kann nichts entstehen.
Verstehe sie müssen sozusagen da sein weil sonst geht's ja das nicht und das nicht kannst nicht geben.
Genau richtig ja.
Okay also die Neutrinos sind eine spezielle Nummer ich meine was kann man denn was oder was was meint man oder was weiß man was man,
quasi jetzt so indirekt über die über den Erkenntnisgewinn,
an weiteren Erkenntnissen gewinnen kann also wenn man sich jetzt Neutrinos anschaut was versucht man dadurch eigentlich zu.
Verstehen wenn ich jetzt sage ok da gibt's Neutrino Quellen was.
Sagt das über den Teil des Universums die man sich anschaut aus.
Genau also erstmal diese Antwort habe leider nicht also das mit diesem da gibt es Neutrino Quellen das ist genau das woran wir arbeiten und die haben wir noch nicht gefunden das wäre sehr spannend es wäre aus folgendem Grund der spannend also seit über 100 Jahren wissen wir dass ich die kosmische Strahlung gibt das ist also,
sprich bekannt als Höhenstrahlung das heißt es kommt irgendwie Strahlung aus dem Weltall von oben raus also jeder der irgendjemand Flugzeug steigen Transatlantikflug hat es in der Strahlung ausgesetzt hat also nein,
höre natürliche radioaktive Belastung und das ist kosmische Strahlung die kommt irgendwo aus dem Weltall Teil hier energetischen Bereich kommt von unserer Sonne aber auch ganz viel kommt von außerhalb.
Diese kosmische Strahlung das wissen wir schon sehr lange die gibt es und die ist eigentlich auch schon relativ gut nachgewiesen wissen aber nicht woher sie kommt,
das können wir bei der kosmischen Strahlung auch gar nicht wissen weil es vorwiegend geladene Strahlung ist also vor allen Dingen Protonen ich glaube sie 99% ungefähr Proton.
Wir sind also elektrisch geladen und was elektrisch geladene Teilchen nur mal so an sich haben ist wenn die sich durch Magnetfelder bewegen dann werden die abgelenkt.
Magnetfelder gibt's am Ende zusammen überall unsere Erde hat ein Magnetfeld die Sonne ein Magnetfeld dazwischen sind Magnetfelder die Galaxie hat man die und so weiter also hier war überall im Universum gibt es irgendwie Magnetfelder,
was heißt nur weil man beispielsweise ein Proton nachweisen kann aus einer bestimmten Richtung kommen heißt das noch lange nicht dass es der ursprünglicher kommt.
So und das ist sozusagen das eine große Rätsel woher kommen diese woher kommt diese kosmische Strahlung auf deiner Seite kennt man natürlich viele Quellen man kennt irgendwie Sternexplosion also Supernovae,
Magenta Lack Tisch aktive galaktische Kerne also irgendwie große Galaxien wurden schwarzes Loch in der Mitte ist also sehr energiereiche Objekte die man irgendwie im elektromagnetischen Bereich sich angeguckt hat mit Teleskopen.
Das weiß man auch aber man hat irgendwie noch nicht bislang diese Verbindung schließen können.
Aber weiß nicht wo die generelle allgemeine kosmische Strahlung eigentlich wirklich herkommt.
Genau man hat natürlich Vorstellung davon also wir wissen ja dass die kosmische Strahlung einerseits gibt andererseits wissen wir dass es ein sehr großes Energiespektrum hat also da werden Energien die irgendwie,
10000000 mal energiereicher sind als alles was wir jetzt z.b. am CERN Teilchenbeschleuniger erreichen können fliegen wahnsinnig viele Grössenordnung dazwischen aber wissen eben nicht woher sie kommt.
Und das ist sozusagen einen eines der großen Rätsel das ist seit über 100 Jahren gibt und da natürlich eine Vorstellung davon also klar wissen wir dass es super nur wer gibt es gibt,
sogenannte Gammastrahlung sexplosion gamma ray birth es gibt diese aktiven galaktischen Kernen irgendwo gibt es ja diese Energie reichen Objekte nur weil konnten bislang noch nicht zweifelsfrei nachweisen ist die kosmische Strahlung auch wirklich daherkommt.
Weil man nicht sagen kann woher sie wirklich kommt weil sie halt an jedem Magnetfeld abprallt was so rumliegt und davon liegen so einige rum.
Also sozusagen eine der Grundideen wäre dass man sich so eine Art himmelskarte anschaut also wenn du nach irgendwas bist vielleicht nicht in Berlin irgendwo ein bisschen dunkler ist und du guckst in den Himmel raus und du siehst alle möglichen Sterne und Galaxien vielleicht sogar die Milchstraße wenn es dunkel genug ist dann machst du ja sozusagen mit deinen Augen eine Messung du machst,
den himmelskarte und weißt okay hier sind ein paar leuchtenden Objekte offensichtlich ist da irgend eine Quelle,
na wenn wir das gleiche wenn du ein Experiment hättest mit dem du die kosmische Strahlung messen würdest also die Ankunft Richtung der kosmischen Strahlung,
du wirst versuchen eine gleiche Hermes gerade zu machen da wer die im Prinzip komplett verarschen du würdest die sozusagen von überall gleichermaßen herkommen sehen.
Und martinus sind insofern interessant weil Neutrinos könnt ihr auch wieder diese diese also diese Quellen Auflösung ermöglichen das heißt wenn du Neutrinos aus einer Richtung mehrfach kommen sie ist dann ist er höchstwahrscheinlich eine Quelle.
Und Neutrinos können aber nur in Zusammenhang mit der kosmischen Strahlung entstehen da heißt wenn wir Neutrinos sozusagen finden.
Jana Weise also eine Neutrino Quelle finden idealerweise vielleicht auch noch.
Im elektromagnetischen Spektrum eine Zusatz Beobachtungen zu machen können dann können wir eine Menge über ein so ein Objekt lernen und auch eine Menge Rückschlüsse dafür ziehen dass das vielleicht ein Kandidat für die.
Und die Neutrino Quelle kann weswegen nur da sein wo auch die kosmische Strahlung herkommt.
Das passiert jetzt sagen es ist am Ende etwas sehr ähnliches was bei uns auch im Teilchenbeschleuniger auf der Erde passiert es werden also irgendwelche Zeichen beispielsweise Protonen lass uns bald online bis der simpelste Fall die werden beschleunigt.
Elektromagnetische Felder die es zuhauf gibt rei bei so gigantischen Explosion wie im Universum passieren.
Diese Proton werden beschleunigt und treffen irgendwo auf umliegende materia also man kann sich vorstellen dass ein Stern explodiert dann wird sozusagen müssen Materie abgestoßen und die findet sich dann irgendwie drumrum und wenn dann sozusagen ein Proton dadurch geflitzt kommt.
Dann kann es eben da stecken bleiben und Wechselwirkung mit dem anderen Proton dann haben wir am Ende genau das gleiche was auch ein Teilchenbeschleuniger americium passiert nur bei viel höheren Energien und die treffen aufeinander und dabei werden eine Menge andere Teilchen erzeugt.
Habe vielleicht schon mal so gesehen was im klassischen Bild wenn so zwei Teichen aufeinanderprallen.
Diesen aufgeschnittenes Wollknäuel.
Ja genau richtig genau so sieht das aus und das gleiche passiert eben auch vermuten wir zumindest bei diesen bei diesem sehr energiereichen Himmelsobjekte so und in dieser Wechselwirkung können Neutrinos entstehen.
Und diese Neutrinos nachdem suchen wir.
Was heißt die Suche nach den Neutrinos ist eigentlich die Suche nach kosmischen Strahlungsquellen.
Zum Teil Unternehmer.
Unter anderem okay gut und wenn es einfach wissen will mal gucken ob ich das noch nicht genau und dann muss man einfach mal genauer hinschauen okay.
Was ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu früh aus, das mal Versende aufsparen was man da vielleicht in Zukunft noch mal suche auslesen kann vielleicht mal so ein bisschen zur ist es jetzt gibt's.
Die Forschung rund um diese Neutrinos und gerade hörten wann war das 53 Paulinus das erste Mal.
SR30 Wolfgang Pauli.
30 pauli und.
Theoretische Vorhersage und 53819.
Die mit der Nachweis also da fing das an quasi an dass die Experimente auch Griffin wie es was hat man jetzt bisher versucht um diesen Neutrinos noch genau auf die Spur zu kommen und zum ist erstmal den Wissensstand herzustellen die wir jetzt haben.
Also da gibt's natürlich eine ganze Reihe von Exponenten die in aller Regel irgendwie erdgebunden sind das,
sehr praktische Methode wäre natürlich wenn man weiß was dafür Neutrinos,
produziert werden also wenn man sozusagen soll Kalibration Quelle hat das kann man beispielsweise bei einem Teilchenbeschleuniger machen das kann man aber auch bei Kernkraftwerken machen das heißt man hat irgendwie Quelle ohne Trikots produziert werden,
und diese Quelle erkennt man relativ gut weil man als ein Teilchenbeschleuniger oder seinen Kernkraftwerk kennt und dann versucht man sozusagen die Eigenschaften von diesem Neutrinos zum essen,
und das wurde auch über viele Jahrzehnte gemacht da hat man z.b. festgestellt dass Neutrino ich hatte ja eingang gesagt dass es drei verschiedene Sorten gibt das die beispielsweise die Sorten,
dass die Sorten wechseln können also wenn sie an ihrem. Entstehen und eine Sorte haben und dann eine gewisse Zeit irgendwie vor sich vorwärts bewegt haben und kurz bevor man sie misst oder wenn man sie Mist zusammen plötzlich eine andere Sorte haben das ist bekannt als Neutrinooszillation da gab's vor ein paar Jahren,
auf den Nobelpreis für Physik.
Wie unterscheiden sich diese Sorten.
Wie unterscheiden sich quasi in der Art welche Sekundärteil kann sie erzeugen das heißt es gibt für das Elektron gibt es ein passendes Elektronen Neutrino,
plasmieren gibt es einmal nur einer drin auch für das Auge des Internet Rhino das heißen taunusbühne würde beispielsweise nachgewiesen indem Santa erzeugten Elektronen Neutrino wurde nachgewiesen intimsten electron erzeugt.
Und sie nachdem wie das Experiment aufgebaut ist kann man eventuell diese unterschiedlichen Signaturen an unterscheiden.
Das heißt wenn dann war das Neutrino dann wechselwirkt merkt man dass dadurch dass diese Teilchen dabei rauskommt.
Um Neutrinos zu sehen muss man eigentlich schauen ob es irgendwo ob es irgendwo so ein Elektroden Produzenten auf einmal gibt es vorher so nicht gab.
Genau aus dem Nichts.
Aus dem Nichts oder Halter oder was auch immer aber die sind dann auch sehr ähnlichen unterschiedlich schwer im Wesentlichen.
Genau Alina trino ist das wissen wir heute nicht so wirklich ob die jetzt unterschiedlich schwer sind oder nicht da also da da gibt es Bemühungen die Masse z.b. zum essen also fragt ist ja sozusagen wie gut verstehen wir die Neutrinos und.
Die Frage nach der Masse ist z.b. immer noch eine sehr sehr ungeklaerter Frage.
Also lass nicht gesagt die haben keine.
Sie sollten keine haben laut im Standardmodell der Teilchenphysik ja.
Aber sie erzeugen Dinge die unter Umständen relativ viel Wasser haben.
Ja das ist das ist noch nicht mein Problem das können die auch aber diese was ich gerade meinte die sind Neutrinooszillation also wenn die plötzlich ihre Sorte ändern das geht das geht nur wenn sie Wasser haben,
und daher wissen wir dass die Masse haben auch wenn wir sie noch nie wirklich direkt gemessen haben.
Also sozusagen also das ist das Ende Dinge die wir über Nadine ausleeren und das kann man natürlich am besten mit Experimenten die auch auf der Erde,
sozusagen dir auf ihre auf der Erde die Quelle haben also Neutrinos aus Kernreaktoren Teilchenbeschleunigern,
der Schritt sozusagen Neutrino Astronomie zu betreiben also sind Neutrinos aus dem Weltall sich anzugucken das ist noch mal ein viel schwieriger Schritt natürlich weil wir die Quellen eben nicht kennen.
Und deswegen müssen wir sozusagen am Ende die Neutrinos durch die erdgebundenen Experimente relativ gut verstehen.
Damit wir sozusagen wissen wonach wir suchen müssen und damit wir sozusagen unsere Exponent auf der Erde auch gut verstehen denn daraus unbekannt untersuchen ist natürlich deutlich schwieriger als nach etwas aus,
was man weiß was auf einen zukommt.
Nörgler.
Was war denn so die Meilensteine und unwichtigen Vorgänger auch des ice cubes die jetzt quasi den Weg bereitet haben was konnte man denn dann schon machen.
Ja also.
Ich glaube an wichtiger. Also Meilensteine in der Neutrino Astronomie sind am Ende natürlich der am Anfang der Vorschlag dass man Neutrinos Zombie betreiben kann.
Und was dafür notwendig ist und ich glaube das war Anfang der 60er Jahre oder erste Vorschlag schon kam okay wenn wir sowas wie Neutrino als Hobby betreiben wollen,
also wirklich Martina aus dem Weltall beobachten am brauchen wir ein sehr sehr großen detector.
Das war also eine der grundlegendsten Pfeiler dieses ganzen Vorhaben und sehr sehr groß heißt in diesem Fall wirklich idealerweise auf der Größenordnung von einem Kubik Kilometer also.
Das ist sozusagen auch.
Weil die Dinger so wenig reagieren und wenn man überhaupt Reaktionen messen will dann muss man sehr großen Betrachtungsraum haben.
Genau genau richtig ja also zum einen reagieren sie sehr selten und zum anderen ist auch eine gute Frage wie viele es davon gibt.
Also es gibt z.b. unsere Sonne produziert permanent Neutrinos und die kommen auch natürlich auf der Erde an und das sind wirklich sehr sehr viele also allein durch deinen Körper gehen 100 Billionen,
von diesen Arduinos also 100 Tausend Milliarden Neutrinos pro Sekunde durch deinen Körper also eine ganze ganze Menge.
Aber das sozusagen tatsächlich mal eines dieser Neutrino was in deinem Körper macht also irgendwie hängen bleibt und was dass ich irgendwie bei dir im Gewebe ist sozusagen feststeckt das passiert nur alle 100 Jahre also müsstest du sehr sehr lange warten bis das mal passiert.
Also ist ein bisschen so wie eine Murmel mit einem sehr grobmaschigen Fischernetz gefangen also extrem schwierig.
Ja
Das sind die solare Neutrinos die interessieren uns noch nicht mal weißt du da gibt es andere Experimente für weil die so niederenergetisch sind wir suchen also nach sehr sehr viel höher energetische Neutrinos.
Und da müsste man sozusagen mit dem gleichen Setup ja dein Körper ist ein Neutrino detector müsstest du schon 100.000 Jahre warten bis du mal ein Neutrino findest.
Okay also es ist an einer Seite die Frage wie viele von diesen Neutrinos gibt es und da ist eben die der Energiebereich indem man sucht sehr Unterschall so sehr wichtig und zum anderen.
Dass die eben auch relativ wenig machen dass sie selten wechselwirken und dann muss man natürlich in der großen Detektor bauen.
Und das wurde in den USA 60er Jahren schon vorgeschlagen aber es hat tatsächlich relativ lange gedauert bis das auch Exponenten umgesetzt wurde und da gabs,
da waren erst das erste Versuche in den Detektor der Dumont heißt der am Ende aber nie gebaut wurde der sozialen er so eine prototypenentwicklung war im Laufe der 70er Jahre das fand auf Hawaii Staat aber da wohnen viele Erkenntnisse gewonnen,
und dann später in den 90er späten 90er Jahren wurde der Amanda detector gebaut ist,
deine Mutter schon angesprochen hattest einen Vorläufer von dem eisgewächs Ferment der ihm auch am Südpol steht.
Und mehr oder weniger parallel dazu ein bisschen später im Mittelmeer auch noch.
Ein anderer Neutrino detector der Antaris heißt der sozusagen große Menge an Wasser im Mittelmeer dafür dafür benutzt.
Und dann natürlich Ice Cube das war der Bau 2004 angefangen und hat dann 7 Jahre gedauert.
Übersicht macht Sinn sich mit den Vorgänger noch und wie groß zu beschäftigen wahrscheinlich nicht weil das waren im Prinzip basieren die alle auf dem selben Konzept.
Genau sie basieren im Endeffekt auf dem selben Konzept also wenn wir weißt du sprechen dann verstehen wir im Wesentlichen auf was Antaris oder Amanda machen also Mittelmeer und der Vorläufer am Südpol,
es ist ja durchaus interessant zu verstehen also dass das sozusagen die geschichtliche Entwicklung dieser Detektoren ist nur Amanda.
Das dass er natürlich Erkenntnisse gesammelt wurden die wichtig waren fight club.
Beispielsweise war ja alles in dem Eis am Südpol passiert und man das Eis nur begrenzt kannte durch Bohrungen,
was natürlich enorm wichtig dass auch erstmal zu testen ob man sozusagen die Eigenschaften des Eises versteht und hat man z.b. festgestellt miteinander oder mit dem Vorläufer sogar voneinander also mit den ersten Tests und Prototypen dass man sehr sehr tief bohren muss im Eis,
Imbiss die bis die Eigenschaften für für soziale Lichtmessung im Eis,
aber auch gut geeignet sind also wenn du sozusagen am Südpol relativ flach nur ein borstar Sangerhausen Paul 100m da sind unheimlich viele Luftblasen im Eis das ist ein unheimlich schlechtes.
Eine schlechte Grundvoraussetzung Unterlicht zum essen weil das unheimlich gestreut wird das ist einer der Gründe.
Was außer einer der Dinge die man gelernt hat mit Amanda auch dass man sehr sehr tief runter gehen muss ins Eis um sozusagen detector zu haben der auch der gut funktioniert.
Geh mal auf auf eisclub und vielleicht auch erstmal noch ein bisschen warum es so ist wie es ist wenn.
Gut Neutrinos reagieren wenig haben wir schon wir wissen noch nicht wie viel da sind die potenziell reagieren können das ganze findet selten statt dann hast du nächste mal wenn man einen einen Ort einen Raum haben wo man auch sehr viel wenig,
andere Dinge.
Patient hat so also soll quasi auch dann klar sein wenn man was sieht dass das nicht durch irgendetwas anderes ausgelöst.
Ist das jetzt der Grund warum man überhaupt ins Eis geht oder ist das der Grund warum man Südpol geht also warum geht man überhaupt dahin.
Ja also das ist teilweise im Grund also alle,
Direktorin die nach Neutrinos suchen egal ob es jetzt solare Neutrinos anderen Artgenossen haben immer als Grundvoraussetzung das Lied tief in die Erde gehen müssen und der Grund dafür ist dass es diese Myonen also die schweren Elektronen,
dass die zuhauf in unsere Atmosphäre produziert werden nämlich immer dann wenn kosmische Strahlung aus dem Weltall auf die Atmosphäre trifft,
jetzt hat sie sowas wie einen Teilchenbeschleuniger auch sonst showers und Wust an weiteren Teilchen und dabei entstehen ganz ganz viele Millionen,
und die werden die kann dich sehr lange sehr weit ausbreiten durch die Luft und auch tief in die Erde eindringen und die tiefer man in die unter die Erde geht desto mehr von diesem Büro werden sozusagen ausgefüllt hat.
Was heißt das ist ein wichtiger eine wichtige Grundvoraussetzung dass man möglichst tief in die Erde geht dass er so ein. Warum man bei Eis subjektiv Defense ausgegangen ist.
Weil man will ja letztenendes diese Umwandlung von Neutrinos in Elektron Myon oder Tausch beobachten.
Diese Wandlung aus dem Nichts die wir mal sehen und wenn sich da ganz viele aus was anderem wandelt dann ist irgendwie der Weg verstellt.
Also man muss tief rein um den Millionen aus dem Weg zu gehen.
Genau richtig das schafft man aber auch eine begrenzte also der Film mit Ice Cube sehen wir immer noch 3000 von diesem Millionen pro Sekunde und natürlich deutlich weniger Neutrinos.
Aber vielleicht mal gerade zurück zu der Frage warum gehen wir an den Südpol,
ohne Grund warum man den Südpol und auch so tief reingehen ist zum einen das selektionsprinzip von Ice Cube das heißt wir messen Neutrinos.
Über sogar über sogenannte cherenkov Strahlung was heißt denn Neutrino bewegt sich irgendwie durch das Eis und wenn wir Glück haben dann wechselwirkt es halt genau in in Icecube in dem Detektor drin und erzeugt andere Teilchen.
Und dieser Teilchen sobald die elektrische Ladung haben und sich sehr sehr schnell bewegen was sie in dem Energiebereich von Eisgekühlter erzeugen die blaues Licht.
Das ein bisschen wie bei so einem Überschallflugzeug also wenn Flugzeug,
wo ist normal ausbreitet dann erzeugt es einfach normale Geräusche aber wenn ich schneller fliegt als der Schall dann durchbricht das sozusagen die Schallmauer und dann gibt es so eine ja man sagt so eine kohärente genauso 1 Korinther ist Schallausbreitung schon richtig lauten Knall,
und das gleiche können Teilchen mehr oder weniger auch machen wenn die sich durch ein Medium bewegen wo das normale Licht ein bisschen langsamer ist.
Also Licht im Vakuum hat mir bestimmt Geschwindigkeit und wenn man jetzt z.b. ein Glas geht oder ein Eis oder irgendwas anderes transparentes dann ist das Licht ein bisschen langsamer als das normales.
So aber diese Teilchen können sich durchaus schneller bewegen und das ist sozusagen genau dieser also nicht schneller als das Licht dass das geht nicht.
Aber schnell ist das Licht im Eis.
Genauer schneller als das Licht im Alter.
Und wenn das passiert dann wird sozusagen yatili sowas wie die lichtmauer durchbrochen und das ist so so ein so ein blauer Knall wenn du so willst also einfach so ein blaues Licht was ausgestrahlt wird.
Das heißt diese Detektion ist Phasin optische Detektion.
Genauso ist eine optische Detektion richtig deswegen sind wir im Eis also wir brauchen etwas was transparent ist und das alles gerade da unten in der Tiefe ist mehr oder weniger transparent.
Weil es quasi rein ist.
Genaues ist ein.
Keine Partikel Feinstaub.
Gibt es auch also aber es ist trotzdem über jahrhundert also Jahrtausende ist es quasi hier nach und nachgewachsen ist ein riesengroßer Gletscher am Südpol,
und er das heißt ganz ganz unten ist eigentlich es ist relativ klar also es kann man,
kann man sich tatsächlich schlecht vorstellen also wenn du irgendwie dir selbst Eiswürfel im Gefrierfach machst unternimmst immer 1 Wort Auge und versuchst du durch zu gucken da siehst du nicht viel das ist weiß und milchig aber das Eis da unten wenn du dir vorstellst zusätzlich Detektiv in diese Blätter rein das ist sehr sehr klar du kannst ja wirklich,
schätzungsweise 20 Meter weit klar gucken und du würdest sogar noch eine Taschenlampe 100 bis 150 m Entfernung.
Den gleichen Effekt hat man wenn man das Wasser vorher gekocht und dann so Eiswürfeln macht dann wird es auch ganz klar auf einmal.
Kann sein ja es geht immer darum dass du sozusagen möglichst wenig Luftblasen im Eis drin haben willst.
Genau die Luft wird er dadurch dann sozusagen effizient rausgeholt und dann hat man so richtig schöne klare Eiswürfel.
Genau erst passiert da tief unten einfach durch den Druck also einfach war soviel von oben runter drückt werden diese Luftbläschen selber kleingedruckt also die sind quasi dann nicht mehr vorhanden.
Aber dafür haben wir auch im Stau also über die Jahrtausende sind irgendwann mal Vulkane ausgebrochen also wir sehen das auch Staub und da wird das Licht dann auch das eklig gestreut und auch absorbiert.
Ist das Ideal.
Nächstes ideal aber es ist schon richtig gut gerade draußen.
Okay gut also wann muss den mühren schon mal aus dem Weg gehen man braucht was transparentes und im Idealfall halt auch ein Medium was wo das Licht gebremst wird sodass wenn.
Ein Neutrino durch dieses Areal durch schieß und dann eben dieser selten Effekt auftritt dass es irgendwie über die schwache Kraft,
interagieren und in dem Moment ein Elektron oder einen Jungen oder ein Tau erzeugt dass es dann diesen,
diese diese diese Licht Schallmauer sozusagen durchbrochen wird und dann ein blauer Fleck entsteht dem man dann optisch detektieren kann.
Und jetzt muss das Ganze sehr weit unten passieren das heißt man hat sich dann so ein Areal genommen von einem Kubik Kilometer.
Genau.
Also erstmal schon mal was war das anderthalb Kilometer unter der Oberfläche jetzt los ne und dann,
ein Kilometer nach unten und das eben über ein Areal von einem Quadratkilometer,
sprich man bohrt dann von oben Löcher rein und lässt dann was da rein.
Genaues Mainbord Löcher rein mit,
einfach heißem Wasser das am einfachsten schmilzt Eis war so lange Bohrer gibt es am Ende auch nicht und dann lässt man dann also nachdem man sozusagen 200 km tief gebohrt hat lässt man dann Kabel runter und an dieser Kabel hängen,
venist digitale optische Module das ist am Ende sowas wie eine Kamera sehr sehr gute Kamera die sozusagen dieses blaue Licht im messen kann.
Meine Nummer zu dem Bauern also mein Mann nimmt heißes Wasser schmilzt quasi so wie groß ist der Kern der darüber wird.
Ich glaube so um die 40 50 Zentimeter.
Okay also relativ großes Loch saugt dann wahrscheinlich das Wasser erstmal alles raus.
Nee das Bild doch bleib tatsächlich drin also die ersten paar Meter werden ausgesaugt aber das wäre das wäre einfach zu viel würde zu viel Energie braucht das Wasser kann der sozialen etwas drin bleiben.
Wie hält man das dann irgendwie über einen Allertal über zweieinhalb Kilometer heißt das man damit ich was runter lassen kann weil wenn es bald wieder friert dann.
Nee so schnell ist das dauert ungefähr eine Woche bis Sonntag wieder zugefroren ist.
Ja und der Bau also dass das Bohren eines solchen lochis dauert ungefähr zwei Tage also es war meine glaube ich eher Durchschnitt und dann so die Konstruktion also das reinlassen und alles fertig machen für ein Bohrloch für ein paar Tage 3-4 Tage.
Okay ich hätte mir jetzt jetzt komplizierter vorgestellt dass was nicht polarkind yamaso Garstigkeit.
Ja ich war nicht dabei ich glaube das Warten schon kompliziert.
Ja ja okay aber ich dachte es wäre schade dass ich kompliziert das wenn man einmal was aufwärmt ist es dann ja auch null Komma nichts wieder fest ist und wenn man das Universum Zeitraum 200 km,
2h zweieinhalb km macht na gut also funktioniert offenbar sowas lässt man jetzt rein und Kabel.
Genau und dann hängt man sozusagen alle 17m hängt man so einen optisches Modul dran dass so eine Kamera ist also eine Runde Kugeln die besteht so aus anderem aus dickem Glas.
Damit es auf dem Druck beim wieder einfrieren standhält und dann ist unten in dieser Kugel ist ist eine photosensitive Fläche das ist sowas wie.
Wie darf das auch in der Kamera verbaut ist nun bisschen anders und darauf also ein Photomultiplier Tube nennt man das sein ein Photon Vervielfacher und da kann sozusagen nicht drauf treffen und wenn er nicht drauf trefft dann kann es das in elektrisches Signal umwandeln.
Und dann ist in dieser optischen modulyss und noch so ein paar Platin rauf ist ein bisschen Computer drauf dass das sozusagen das Signal auch direkt digitalisiert wird.
Und dann kannst du sagen ein so ein optisches Modul ist eine bedeckt eine eigenständige detektions Einheit wann immer das Licht irgendwie sieht kann es das über über die Zeit sozusagen messen und das Signal nach oben geben.
Und die ganze Apparatur kriegt von Romy an Strom.
Da hat ein Bohrloch also man packt dann alle 17m packt man so ein optisches Modul daran lässt das Kabel weiter runter bis man 60 von diesen Modulen dran hat dann hat man also 60 Module an einem Kabel in der Höhe von ungefähr einem Kilometer also zwischen anderthalb Kilometer.
Was ist das sowieso eine Weihnachtsbaum Lichterkette so eins nach dem anderen oder hat er jeder sein eigenes Kabel.
Nee nee das ist ein kabel eins nach dem anderen die werden da alles angeschlossen.
Warum muss man also drauf achten dass da keine Fehler mache keine Fehler reinlegt weil wenn einer kaputt ist also wenn irgendwo das Kabel gebrochen ist und die Weiterleitung nicht funktioniert dann ist vorbei so.
Ja also die Weiterleitung funktioniert schon übers Kabel also es hat nicht sollen einen optischen Module in der Mitte kaputt geht das man den ganzen dieses ganze Kabel wegschmeißen kann.
Personenbus dann an dem alle gleichberechtigt dranhängen.
Aber ist das richtig so und man muss sehr aufpassen die wurden sehr Rivalität Sicherung von diesem optischen Modulen war sehr wichtig denn wenn die doch einmal runtergelassen sind und eingefroren ist da kommen wir nicht mehr dran.
Also das sind auch ein paar beim Einlassen und beim Bau selbst bevor sozusagen der Detektor fertig war dann auch ein paar kaputt gegangen und die waren seither haben wir in Benutzung aber glücklicherweise haben wir ja von diesem Bohrlöchern dann am Ende 86 Stück,
sodass wir über 5000 von diesen optischen Motoren haben.
5000 alles ist so quasi so ein,
darf der Name schon so schön sagt ein Ice Cube also ein großer Würfel der immer 17 m Abstand von unten nach oben und wie weit sind dann die einzelnen Kabel voneinander entfernt.
Komische 125m.
Okay warum macht man in der Einrichtung eine andere Auflösung als in der anderen.
Also vor allem hat es eine technische Gründe wenn man eine das aufwendigste ist das Loch bohren.
Das heißt es macht einfach mehr Sinn sozusagen mehr optische Module in die Vertikale wenn man schonmal und doch gebohrt hat anzusetzen als noch mehr Löcher zu bohren.
Auf der anderen Seite diese Abstand 125m zwischen Bohrlöchern ist schon mit Bedacht gewählt worden nämlich weil eben die absorptionslänge also Wann liegt sozusagen wirklich verschwindet so um in der Größenordnung 100 bis 150 m ist.
Das also sagen genau der der Abstand so gewählt dass wenn man was ich meinte der taschenlampe sozusagen von einem Bohrloch in Richtung des andere hält dass man es zumindest aussehen würde vielleicht nicht scharf aber zumindest noch das Licht sehen will.
Ah okay du hast noch die Möglichkeit hat einen Effekt auf der einen Seite auch in dem anderen Kabelstrang noch mitzubekommen.
Genau und das wird auch gemacht also wir haben an jedem diese optische Module haben wir LEDs und die kann man aufblitzen lassen und zum testen so können wir sozusagen das Eis dazwischen modellieren und beschreiben.
Okay das heißt man hat auch gleich sein eigenen Simulator und Test Apparat quasi gleich mit runter gelassen ganz klug eigentlich.
Genau richtig ja ja haben sich Leute was bei gedacht.
Erstaunlich wie viel Grips aber wieder rein fließt.
Okay das hat was schon gesagt wie lange dauert 2 Jahre.
Der der Bau insgesamt hatte 7 Jahre gedauert weil halt immer nur im australischen Sommer angebaut werden konnte also ungefähr von November bis Februar weil im Winter ist dunkel zu kalt.
Ja mach keinen Spaß.
So also hat jetzt die ganze Lampe aus Tag war sie in Eis rein gehalten und festfrieren lassen oben kommt das alles zusammen.
Welcher Land eigentlich die ja die eigentliche detektions Apparatur ist ja eigentlich recht simpel.
Guckt einfach nur ist da Licht oder nicht weil normalerweise ist da keins und da unten kommt ja auch kein Licht von oben mehr an oder.
Totale Dunkelheit so oder hat man sich hingesetzt und gewartet dass es irgendwie das was passiert.
Ja ja so gewartet hat glaube ich niemand fahren alle natürlich währenddessen sehr fleißig also nein ganz simpel ist es natürlich nicht,
es gibt natürlich viele Fragestellungen auch viele Probleme also zum 1 was du sagst natürlich haben wir keine Lichtquelle das ist schon mal super das heißt wir müssen uns nicht beschäftigen dass es z.b. ganz anders in dem Antaris extrement was im Mittelmeer ist weil er Mittelmeer gibt es Biolumineszenz das heißt goodbye Jersey luminose Fische,
wenn die durch deine tektor fließt dann hast du Untergrund Licht was du nicht möchtest das haben wir Mais natürlich nicht.
Aber wir haben Untergründe Untergründe die uns eigentlich interessieren das ist normales normale Radioaktivität,
die auch unten im Eis vorkommt beispielsweise im Glas von unseren optischem und holen die es nicht ganz so kritisch weil die eben sehr sehr niederschwellig von der Energie ist aber wir haben eben diese ganzen mironglas Atmosphäre kommen.
Da kommen halt immer noch um die 3000 pro Sekunde in diesem Detektor an.
Das ist ganz schön Spielverderber.
Genau das ist das ist ganz schön viel wenn man bedenkt dass die Neutrinos die wir suchen die die aus dem Universum, je nachdem wie man sozusagen die Selektion macht und wie man wie man daran arbeitet so in der Größenordnung 1 pro Monat ist.
Aber erzeugen die auch automatisch diesen selben Lichteffekt.
Genau also da geht es am Ende darum die Lichtausbreitung in dem Eis relativ gut zu verstehen.
Weil vom Grundsatz her ist es beispielsweise sozusagen wir eben gelernten Myon Neutrino würde ja eine Wechselwirkung anhören erzeugen und anhören.
Ist erstmal völlig identisch zu nominieren was aus der Atmosphäre kommt,
eine ganz simple Sache die man dass sich relativ leicht machen kann ist beispielsweise eine Richtung,
würde sich die Richtung anzugucken wenn man das hinkriegt dass man irgendwelche Computer Algorithmus schreibt und dann sozusagen die Richtung von so einem Ereignis messen kann,
dann könnte man beispielsweise sagen ok mich interessieren eigentlich nur die Möhren die von unten nach oben in den Detektor laufen dann wenn Sie das tun dann müssen sie sozusagen einmal durch die Erde.
Wo ist sein und das können nur Neutrinos das kann ich mir und machen das heißt man würde sozusagen durch die Erde gucken da kommt dann irgendwie Neutrino durch die Erde durch.
Und dann irgendwo unten im Gestein oder unterhalb des Detektors im ICE kann so ein Neutrino irgendwo wechselwirken und Mandarine und Möhren erzeugen und dann hätte man eine Möhren was einmal quer durch den Text von unten nach oben läuft.
Was für eine Leuchtspur erzeugt immer.
Sonne Leuchtspur genau.
Wie wie lange muss man sich so eine Leuchtspur vorstellen.
Für Millionen durch den kompletten Detektoren und kilometerlange ungefähr die Fliegen sehr sehr weiter.
Aber dadurch dass man quasi an verschiedenen Stellen misst hat man unterschiedliche Zeitereignisse und kann unterscheiden ob etwas von unten nach oben oder von oben nach unten gehen.
Genau also man kann sich das so vorstellen dass man so ein A3 4D Bild bekommen also man hat sozusagen eine räumliche Position im Detektor wo diese Spur lang geht und dann kann man natürlich noch die Zeit Zeit man kann sich wieso ein eigenes Visum Video angucken wie sich das so langsam ausbreitet.
Und genau daran kann man eben die Position und auch die Richtung bestimmen.
Aber ansonsten könnte man von den Millionen aus Atmosphäre gar nicht unterscheiden nur daran.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr sichere Methode,
andere Methode ist noch die Energie also die Millionen aus der Atmosphäre haben sozusagen anderes Energiespektrum was heißt bei sehr hohen Energien es ist er erstmal unwahrscheinlicher dass Möhren aus unsere eigene Atmosphäre kommt,
Gegenwart Rinus wurden zumindest angenommen dass sie in etwas dass Sie solange etwas steilere Energiespektrum haben das heißt bei höheren Energien erwarten sozusagen im Vergleich mehr Neutrinos,
diese Möhren aus der Atmosphäre das heißt man kann sozusagen auch mit Hilfe der Energie und die Energie würde man messen einfach die Menge an Licht ja also je mehr Licht sozusagen mehr blaues Licht,
Lügendetektor im eisgrub erzeugt wird desto mehr Energie hat das Teilchen sozusagen was dadurch fliegt.
Und das lässt sich sozusagen dadurch messen und das heißt es gibt so ein paar Methoden wie man jemanden was von einem Neutrino kommt unterscheiden kann zu einem jungen was aus der Atmosphäre kommt.
Noch eine Nachfrage zu Energie ist ja auch immer so ein so ein generischer Begriff wie wie wie macht sich das also wann macht man das fest dass ein Neutrino mehr Energie hat es bewegt sich schneller.
Nein das ist ja das spezielle Relativitätstheorie also bei der Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist Schluss,
und dann bedeutet sozusagen am Ende das mehr Energie bedeutet das sagen das Zeichen immer schwerer wird das ist bei Neutrino jetzt natürlich eine Sache weil wenn ich genau also eigentlich genau wissen ob sie was hat oder nicht.
Nein aber im Bezug auf Icecube ist es einfach nur die Frage wie viel Licht wird erzeugt und.
Wie schwer ist die Teilchen die letzten ist aber rauskommt.
Aber weniger eigentlich es geht eigentlich mehr also wir bewegen uns hier wirklich in dem Energiebereich der der millionenfach über dem ist was wir beim Teilchenbeschleuniger am CERN sehen kann,
was heißt im Wesentlichen geht es darum nicht so was für eine Masse ist da von den Teichen da rauskommt sondern wie viele von den Teichen komm da raus.
Zeige mehr Energie Sommer Spezies Neutrino hatte bestem desto größer ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sehr sehr viel mehr Teilchen erzeugt werden und je mehr Teilchen desto mehr blaues Licht.
So es läuft alles was da los da unten also passiert überhaupt was oder ist ewige Dunkelheit uns kommen nur ab und zu mal ein paar Minuten aus Atmosphäre runter geregnet.
Nein da passiert natürlich eine ganze Menge also tatsächlich sind die meisten diese Millionen ab,
es gibt eine Möglichkeit ich hatte ja eben eine gesagt dass wenn man neben sich angucken die von unten nach oben gehen dass das wahrscheinlich Neutrinos sind das andere was ich eingangs meinte ist das Neutrino sozusagen nicht selbst.
Web keine Spur hinterlassen das heißt dass sie sozial aus dem Nichts kommen und das machen wir uns auch mit Eis gibt's nur zusagen einfach sozusagen der äußere Rand von Ice Cube da darf sozusagen kein Licht sein und dann haben wir sozusagen wenn was innerhalb von diesem,
ICE Q Protektor passiert dann wissen wir dass es dort beginnt und dann kann es sozusagen nur Neutrino sein.
Und das ist so eine Herangehensweise die war sehr erfolgreich und mit dieser angehensweise haben wir vor ein paar Jahren tatsächlich auch zum erstmal nachweisen können dass es Neutrinos gibt die wirklich aus dem Universum kommen die nicht in unserer eigenen Atmosphäre entstehen sondern eben,
irgendwo im Weltall entstehen und Darm.
90310 Wadersloh.
Zwanzigdreizehn genau das war dann sozusagen die die Entdeckung des Jahres und seitdem wurde diese Analyse also diese Suche nach diesen Neutrino ist auch immer wieder aktualisiert und mittlerweile sind wir so in der Größenordnung was versuchen,
Ereignisse ungefähr 100 Kilo Ereignisse die und natürlich erlauben,
zusätzlich zu vielen anderen Analysen und suchen die mit Eis gemacht worden und die Schlussfolgerung erlauben lassen dass wir definitiv Neutrinos gefunden haben die irgendwie aus dem Universum kommen das war also eine tatsächlich eine sehr wichtige Erkenntnis war das zum ersten Mal.
Was ist jetzt mit den Vorgängern so nicht.
Genau das ist mit dem Vorgänger nicht gelungen also von wirklich 1960 der erste Vorschlag lass uns doch mal Kilometer großen Detektor bauen um diese Neutrinos zu suchen bis zur Entdeckung 2013 ist wirklich eine Menge Zeit und auch eine Menge Arbeit rein geschlossen.
Und,
ja damit müssen wir asozial haben wir die Antwort auf die Frage ja oder nein gibt es diesen Neutrinos aus dem Weltall und das haben wir beantwortet und wir haben die energiereichsten Neutrinos aller Zeiten am Ende gemessen also über 100 mal energiereicher ist das was am CERN MRRC mögliches.
Und jetzt ist natürlich die große Frage woher kommen die und das ist das was ich anfangs meinte was wir noch nicht wirklich beantworten.
Hoffe darauf gehen dass das am Anfang schon von erstes genannt.
Neutrino Astronomie gesprochen dia.
Eben nicht die Astronomie mit elektromagnetischen Wellen ist weil wir sind ganz allein Kraft zu tun haben Neutrinos haben mit romantischen Wellen nichts zu schaffen.
Und wenn ihr 20/13 diese Erkenntnis kam wunder ich mich jetzt gerade warum das eigentlich hier nicht eine breite Medienflut ausgelöst hat zwei Jahre später und das hat man ja warum seid ja auch schon ausführlich gewürdigt,
Gazette gravitationswellendetektor I oder Wasserfilter ja genau um 16:15 Uhr habe ich die Messungen.
Von dem Zeitraum und auch.
Die gravitationswellenastronomie ist ja quasi so ein komplett neues Kapitel der Beobachtung der des Universums,
weil eben auch hier kann erlebt man München wählen,
zum Einsatz kommen aber sozusagen einen ein Highlight der öffentlichen Aufmerksamkeit verpasse es doch eigentlich schon ganz interessanter Durchbruch oder.
Auf jeden Fall ist es.
Man weiß halt noch nicht so genau was dahinter ist wird man bei der Gravitationswellen gesagt hat hier guck mal das waren genau hier diese beiden schwarzen Löcher unsere.
Genau richtig also es ist es natürlich so das war ein absolutes Highlight an das war auf jeden Fall ein Durchbruch für die Neutrino Astra mir war so gesehen was der Beginn der Neutrino ist um wir haben zum ersten Mal Neutrinos auf dem Weltall gemessen,
das muss man auch klar festhalten und das ist auch ein Highlight nun ist genauso wie du sagst wir haben sozusagen gesehen und haben sie mehr oder weniger abgezählt,
aber es hat noch nicht klar wir haben noch nicht wirklich gesagt hier wenn ihr da hoch guckt genau an dieser Stelle.
Da kommen wir ja.
Und diese Frage haben wir noch nicht beantworten.
Aber die Richtung war doch dann klar.
Genau aber es ist ja nur eine Handvoll reicht bei ihm gesagt es war mittlerweile so um die 100.
Und mit 100 Neutrinos wenn du die mal auf dem himmelskarte schmeißt dann hast du einmal links einmal rechts ein aber du kannst dazu sagen ich sagen ok alle Hunde kommen genau aus dieser Richtung und das ist unsere Quelle.
Aber die Richtung ist schon ziemlich genau bestimmen.
Relative nachdem was ist für Neutrino ist lässt sie sich da genau bestimmen also Wörner trinus können wir sehr viel besser auflösen als elektronotdienst.
Bei den längeren Strahl machen.
Genau die wissen was sie machen überhaupt eine Spur durch den Detektor die Elektroherd Rhino stehen heraus wie so ein Ball und von dem Ball ist es ein bisschen schwieriger Einrichtung.
Verstehe das heißt da müsste man dann mehr davon haben.
Genau ich weiß es einfach eine fundamentale schwierigere Auflösung.
Von den aber dass das macht man durchaus auch da sie werden da auch mit rein genommen um zu gucken es ist ja am Ende eine statistische Auswertung kommen am sozusagen komme aus einer Richtung mehrere überlagern die sich irgendwie man hat ja auch nur eine begrenzte Auflösung.
Bruder wir haben quasi mit dem Fischernetze Murmel gefangen und wusstet auch noch wo sie herkommt ist irgendwie jetzt auch nicht so schlecht.
Genau und also,
bleibt natürlich auch weiterhin spannend also es ist ein bisschen also weil du auch die Gravitationswellen ansprichst ist natürlich tatsächlich spannend dass innerhalb von 5 Jahren wirklich zwei große Türen zu einer neuen,
ja am Ende neue Tür zum Weltall aufgestoßen wurden einmal Neutrino wirklich Neutrino Astronomie zu machen und auf deiner Seite gravitationswellenastronomie mit Gravitationswellen zugemacht,
also so dass bei den Gravitationswellen ich hätte mal salopp sagen würde die Tür ist schon auf gestoßen und jetzt jetzt wird's auf jeden Fall spannend was da alles noch kommt.
Bei der Neutrino Astronomie sind halt so ein bisschen wir haben sie wären sie aufgestoßen so ein bisschen aber er ist nur so ein Spalt und wir versuchen Sie jetzt Schritt für Schritt weiter aufzuschieben und da ist sozusagen das Coco eines der nächsten großen Ziele wirklich eine Quelle ausfindig zu machen und da geht ganz viel Arbeit auch im DC geht ganz viel Arbeit da rein,
und dass man sozusagen nur so kombinierte Programme macht das man guckt, trinus irgendwas eine Richtung mehrere hintereinander,
und dass man dann sagt ok hier ist was gekommen das ist interessant mit schicken wir sozusagen automatischen Alarm und ganz viele optische Teleskope auf der Welt raus und guck mal bitte alle in die Richtung ob ihr auch im optischen,
beispielsweise was steht da plötzlich eine Explosion.
So wie man das ja bei den Gravitationswellen auch macht.
Genauso wie man das da auch macht.
Vielleicht wird das ja auch so sagen was ist das vorstellbar dass diese beiden Ereignisse.
Ja das wird gemacht also die diese Arbeit passiert sozusagen also wir gucken uns mit Ice Cube genauso die Gravitationswellen die Orte von Gravitationswellen an wie die andersrum also da gibt es sozusagen Zusammenarbeit.
Bei meiner nicht so richtig ausrichten kann also ich meine Mann ist ja quasi davon abhängig was ankommt.
Genau das hat ein Vorteil wir müssen alles gebraten ich ausrichten als youcook permanent in alle Richtungen.
Ja oder sie ja schaut nur im Datensatz aufzuzeigen irgendwas aus dieser Richtung kam.
Und aber auch tatsächlich sunlive also wir gucken permanent und wenn da was interessantes passiert dann können wir innerhalb von Minuten sozusagen alarm rausschicken an andere Teleskope die sich ausrichten müssen um dann tatsächlich dort zu beobachten.
Ja was denn deine konkrete Beschäftigung jetzt bei dem Projekt abgesehen davon dass du so den Überblick hast.
Also ich habe mich konkret mit meiner Doktorarbeit habe ich mich mit der Suche nach taunatours beschäftigt also dieser dritten Sorte von,
Xenos was ist so dass der Highschool läuft da jetzt tatsächlich schon seit 2004 ist der Bau begonnen hat und seit 2010 in seiner vollen Konfiguration ausgehandelt schon eine ganze Menge an Daten und können daran sozusagen auch bestimmte suchen machen und in diesen Daten haben wir über viele Jahre hinweg diese Spuren gesehen also die Mühle Neutrinos,
und auch seit einigen Jahren eben diese,
Isabelle quasi also die von Elektro Neutrinos kommen aber Taunus haben noch mal eine ganz andere Signatur und da ist ein bisschen schwieriger das heißt wir haben,
mit ICE gefahren wir noch keine Tonart Rhenus beobachtet nur die anderen beiden Sorten und ich habe mich komplett damit beschäftigt sozusagen nach diesem Ton edgen auszusuchen.
Aus dem existierende Datenmaterial.
Außerdem existieren Datensatz R.
Ladeboden vielleicht waren die da schon wir haben Sie bloß noch nicht als solche wahrgenommen.
Genau also wie sie müssen sozusagen da sein also alle unsere Modelle alles geballte physikalische Wissen der letzten Jahrzehnte sagt voraus dass wenn wir eben noch Dinos aus dem Weltall haben,
das ist auch 300 - geben muss es ist nur sie müssen sozusagen da sein aber sie sind eben besonders schwer.
Weil das so nervig ein lichkeit Regel folgt oder.
Weil sie sehr sehr ähnlich aussehen wie elektronotdienst also sie sie sie muss man quasi experimentell versuchen zu unterscheiden also hast 100 Kilo ist an sich schwer zu zum essen also I Ex und Helena.
Ich meine sie müssen sie müssen da sein wenn die anderen beiden da sein dann ist es eine reine Wahrscheinlichkeit Frage dass die anderen auch da sind oder bedingt sich physikalisch also.
Se
Bringt sich physikalisch aufgrund dieser Neutrinooszillation von den ich ihm sprach dass der sozusagen an einem Punkt wunderino erzeugt wird und sich irgendwie fortbewegt dass es auf dem Weg irgendwas eine Sorte ändert.
Unter dieser Weg im Universum ist am Ende lang genug zwischen irgendwelchen Quellen und der Erde dass das Neutrinos eine Sorte permanent endete.
Also dass ein Neutrino rotiert quasi durch alle Phasen immer wieder durch.
Ja mehr sowieso sagen mehrere Neutrinos am Ende aber genau die rotieren durch und weil sozusagen dieser Weg am Ende lang genug ist würde man von allen Sorten genau gleich viele Anteile erwarten.
Versteht das hat gesagt ich eigentlich relativ sicher dass die auch dabei sind die habt bloß noch nicht ich habe noch keine Methode gefunden um sie aus zuverlässig herauszulesen auslesen Gartensalat.
Genau richtig.
Und machine learning oder jetzt hier geht man richtig.
Maschinenring wird auch benutzt ja ich habe es nicht benutzt aber auch benutzt.
Ja also dann schon fast eine mathematische softwaretechnische Arbeit Kassel.
Auf jeden Fall also wir wir programmieren alle wir schreiben sozusagen Algorithmen die bestimmte stimmt Ereignisse analysieren auf irgendwelche Eigenschaften und dann sozusagen selektieren sagen ja das interessant nein das ist nicht interessant.
Aber.
Hast du schon irgendwie ein Ansatz gefunden also was machst du jetzt so so schwierig dass die dass die Daten also.
Ich versuche gerade zu verstehen was füttert man da hat soll ich meine wenn jetzt die ich durcheinander kommt im demion Neutrinos angeschossen kommentiere lange Leuchtspur machen.
Okay ist einfach viele Direktion ist hell alles super die Elektronen.
Neutrinos die machen kleine blaue Punkte sieht man auch sind halt keine Spuren.
Wo müsste das 1000 jetzt irgendwo dazwischen befinden und es geht nur darum zu unterscheiden ob sitzen. Oder eine Linie ist oder.
Passt genau genau der richtige Ansatz und Hundetrainer macht am Ende sozusagen zwei Bälle.
Die wahrscheinlichste also du sozusagen meine Arbeit hatte sich darauf fokussiert dass man versucht diese zwei Bälle sozusagen auseinanderzuhalten.
Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist am größten wenn ein taunuskrimi wechselwirkt und diese zwei Bälle sozusagen diese zwei lichtbälle erzeugt dass sie sehr sehr dicht beieinander sind und es wird durchaus möglich aber immer unwahrscheinlicher dass die sehr weit voneinander getrennt sind,
also da kann durchaus 500m,
auseinander sein das könnte man in einem Kubik Kilometer auf dem Detektor eben sehr sehr gut auflösen aber diese eigenes so ein Ereignisse sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich weil das nur bei sehr sehr hohe Energien auftritt,
viel wahrscheinlicher ist es diese zwei lichtbälle sehr dicht beieinander sind eher so eine Größenordnung ein paar Meter 10 Meter 20 m sind dieser,
kannst du dir vorstellen wenn du wenn du zwei lichtbälle 20 m voneinander entfernt hast und deine nächsten optische Module sind irgendwie auf 100 m Entfernung und dazwischen wird Licht gestreut dass es irgendwo eine Auflösungsgrenze gibt dass man die beiden irgendwann nicht mehr unterscheiden kann,
und da ist sozusagen daran habe ich gearbeitet dass man versucht diese Auflösungsgrenze möglichst weit runter zu kriegen und dann ist es am Ende so,
das ist immer noch sehr sehr schwierig und in 6 Jahren würde man sozusagen nur so erwarten dass man vielleicht ein maximal zwei von diesen 300 Rhinos tatsächlich,
sehen also identifizieren kann das heißt das nur sehr sehr kleine Zahl mit mit also eine sehr kleine Erwartung mit der wir arbeiten.
Euch mal dass er noch Platz im ICE meine könnt ja jetzt im Prinzip hingehen und noch mal sagen ok dann war 125 m Abstand vielleicht doch nicht so gute Idee Bomber noch mal dazwischen noch mal jeweils zwei Reihen sowas die Kohle halt hergibt und dann haben wir auch eine entsprechende,
höhere Auflösung in der Richtung.
Das stimmt genau du hast nur so ein bisschen das Problem du musst auf du musst ab wegen Auflösung gegen Detektor Volumen das wurde das hier auch gemacht in Ice Cube gibt es so ein so ein unter Detektor nennt sich deepcore da wurde genau das gemacht da wurde zwischen die Bohrlöcher noch mal gebohrt,
kannst du ein bisschen enger zusammen zu machen und dann passiert genau das was du sagst du hast eine bessere Auflösung ja du kannst sozusagen mehr Icons über niedrigen Energien sehen und die besser auflösen,
Problem ist nur du hast ein kleineres detector Volumen und was wir eben gelernt haben ist wenn du etwas kleiner machst Detektor dann singt auch deine Rate mit der du etwas meisten kannst.
Neues Handy speichern wieso ist das Tivoli welches Volumen ist kleiner.
Dass dass dass das Volumen an ice also da der texture sozusagen drin ist also wenn du.
Also was das Eis was die defekte umgibt.
Da wo der Detektor sitzen drin ist das instrumentierter eisproduzent Kameras drin sind das Eis mit dem wir was messen kann.
Also insgesamt sozusagen weil man wenn man mehr von dem Gesamteiweiß mit Technik füllt und warum ist das ein Problem.
Das Problem ist halt du bist es so groß wie möglich machen ja also das war sie eigentlich meinte dass er Gefühle Neutrinos durch den Körper gehen aber nur alle 100 Jahre mal Neutrino was macht.
Und jetzt ganz simpel wenn du jetzt irgendwie wenn wir jetzt nicht nur wenn wir Detektor bauen der so groß ist wie du und das ganz aber 100 Mal größer machen dann sehen wir halt auch 100 mal sehen was auch hundertmal mehr.
Lies mir wollen sozusagen detector einfach sehr sehr groß bauen weil Aldi sind Neutrinos zum einen nicht so oft vorkommen und zum anderen halt der Seitenwechsel wirken.
Und wenn wir jetzt sozusagen notwendigerweise du hast von mir aus nur 80 von diesem Bohrlöchern und Stadt die jetzt und wie weit auseinander zu machen machst du sehr eng zusammen dann schrumpft notwendigerweise dein Volumen wo wie du die Bohrlöcher an ordnen kann.
Also gut ich meinte ja jetzt nicht dass man dann quasi etwas mit weniger Ausdehnung baut sondern nur noch mehr auf dieselbe Fläche quasi noch mehr Löcher noch mit dazu nimmt um einfach die innere Auflösung zu erhöhen.
Genau aber du wirst asozialen das wird auch gemacht das ist ein das ein Vorschlag für die Zukunft ja also zweite Generation Ice Cube dass man detector am Ende noch noch größer baut also noch mal 10 mal größer,
das heißt dann würde zwischen zwei Bohrlöcher und jetzt nicht mehr 125ml sondern die doppelte Doppel Abstandshalter 52m machen.
Weiter voneinander.
Weiter voneinander entfernt.
Ja irgendwie damit man diese Tower Übergänge quasi feiner messen kann.
Genau also du kannst wie gesagt nicht beides machen dass du das meinte ich eben wenn du enger zusammen machst dann kannst du diese Übergänge besser messen aber du reduzierst sozusagen die die möglich Neutrinos die du überhaupt messen kannst wenn du den Detektor größer brauchst,
hast du einfach mehr Volumen mit dem du Sozialwesen Neutrinos messen kann.
Aber was ist wenn man beides macht also jetzt das Ding auf.
Geht das Duell geht das Geld aus.
Ja okay gut ich meine das weiß ich gerade die Realität mühselig arbeiten wollte aber,
nur so rein vom vom Dänischen also angenommen würde sagen ok jetzt machen wir da nicht einmal ein km sollen wir machen zweimal Zeit 10 km ist.
Aber wir haben dann halt auch dementsprechend mehr Messpunkte und wir stapeln die zusätzlich aber auch noch mal enger.
Also machen was weiß ich alle 50 m,
ein würde schon jetzt für die Tower Neutrino Nachweis gegebenenfalls Daten liefern die das noch mal einfacher machen würde.
Auf jeden Fall das wäre natürlich das wär natürlich super.
Ich dachte schon der spricht jetzt irgendwas grundsätzlich ist AG.
Nee nee das nur Geld Frage am Ende.
Okay ist eine Geldfrage na gut aber ist meine ist natürlich wie immer Grundlagenforschung ist teurer und viele Leute fragen sich halt immer ja was in aller Welt mach dir da hier sitzen wir haben Südpol und mest,
Dinge die eigentlich mit uns nichts zu tun haben wollen aber ich denke aber auch schon aufgezeigt,
das ist natürlich hier sehr wohl ein Potenzial gibt und das ist eben so etwas ist von jemandem heute noch überhaupt gar nicht sagen kann welche Durchbrüche,
erstmal bringen kann genauso wie das mit den Gravitationswellen ja auch der Fall war kann an der Stelle auch noch mal auf die Sendung verweisen die ich dazu gemacht habe die ich extrem bemerkenswert fand nicht nur weil das Thema,
bemerkenswert ist sondern weil ich finde dass die Sendung das auch ganz gut aufgezeigt hat welche Dynamik da drin steckt und manchmal auch welche,
Zufälle denn das wo dran du arbeitest ist ja quasi auch so dieses okay jetzt können wir was messen.
Aber was können wir denn da eigentlich draus,
ableiten und die Besonderheit der ersten Gravitationswellen Messung war ja gar nicht war nur so dass man sie gemessen hat sein dass man auch schon in anderen Forschungsgruppen,
durch Mathematiker vorher relativ klar vorhergesagt wurde naja und wenn es so aussieht dann handelt es sich um das und dann kannst du ja noch zwei Parameter einsetzen weiß auch wie groß die beiden schwarzen Löcher sind und dann kam ja genau das.
Und die haben ja auch selber geglaubt dass wieder irgendjemanden prank ausgepackt hat weil das war einfach zu perfekt dass da gleich das erste Mal kam und im Prinzip.
Musste hier vermutlich auch entsprechende Arbeit noch geleistet werden und man kann jetzt noch gar nicht sagen was irgendwann mal daraus vielleicht gelesen werden kann,
insbesondere im Zusammenhang mit den anderen beiden Astronomie disziplinarsenat elektromagnetischen Wellen wo er schon eine Menge geht und eben den Gravitationswellen.
Genau alles bleibt auf jeden Fall spannend wenn es gerade wenn man Neutrinos und beispielsweise Gravitationswellen oder auch optisches Licht oder andere Dinge gleichzeitig auf eine Richtung messen kann das ist mega spannend und das wird auch schon bleiben.
Was auch immer.
Am Südpol ja weiß ich genau kalt.
Nein alles was ist es tatsächlich ein unheimlich interessanter sehr außergewöhnlicher Ort.
Also welche Vorstellungen noch immer hat am Ende kommt es glaube ich anders es ist sehr trocken das ist sehr kalt die Luft ist dünn aber es ist tatsächlich phänomenal interessant und es ist wirklich einfach weiß,
soweit man gucken kann weil bei schlechtem Wetter kannst du den Horizont den Himmel vom Boden unterscheiden.
Schlechtwetter achso weit blau und Soja.
Bei gutem Wetter sind unterschiedliche Weißtöne.
Wie kommt man dahinter sodass über Australien dann oder.
Genau also Mannheim 2 Kaarst mal line Flugradar 1 bis nach Neuseeland fährt warum so ungefähr so anderthalb Tage dauert das bis man dann in Christchurch ist,
dann in Christchurch geht man in so einem Jahr so eine Antarktisstation da kriegt man dann seine Ausrüstung auf natürlich spezielle Kleidung haben die einen warm hält,
und von dort geht man dann in Transportmaschine vom ehemalige Transportmaschine vom US Militär,
und er da fliegt man dann an die Küste der Antarktis an die US Station McMurdo.
An der Ostsee und dann muss man noch mal umsteigen also der Flug dauert auch noch mal so ungefähr neun Stunden und von dort steigt man dann noch mal um,
und geht noch mal auf dem Flug bis zum Südpol das dann noch mal so dreieinhalb Stunden.
Also von Neuseeland aus was jetzt schon Ede weit entferntester Ort also kreisfeld ist ja so ziemlich genau einmal durch die Erde von Berlin auf der anderen Seite und dann noch mal 9 Stunden.
Und noch mal dreieinhalb und tatsächlich wenn man Pech hat die Fliegen halt Aufsicht.
Das heißt man hat alt auch keine Garantie dass man dann wirklich ankommt weil wenn sich irgendwie eine Stunde Verlandung das Wetter schlagartig ändert und die kann nicht landen und Randy wieder um Netflix zu 9 Stunden zurück nach Christchurch oder probierst du es am nächsten Tag vielleicht noch mal.
Wo ist der aber nicht passiert.
Zum Glück nicht aber Kollegen kenne ich den ist das passiert was ist was ist das.
Begabt erstmal nervlich am Arsch der Welt ne.
Ja ich glaube wenn du tatsächlich in Neuseeland sagst ja ich habe jetzt die halbe Strecke hinter mir hat dann kannst du sagen dass es am Arsch der Welt.
Okay und dann also wie geht das auch so einer Station zu.
McMurdo.
McMurdo genau das ist die Station dies bisschen größer das ist fast so ein bisschen wie der Vater so eine kleine Stadt also besteht eigentlich aus vielen Häusern ist direkt an der Küste da sind Doppel und Sommer so zwischen 1500 2500 Leuten.
Da geht das eigentlich sehr also klar was gibt natürlich Regeln an die muss man sich halten man kriegt ein Briefing wenn man da ankommt also eine Sicherheitsunterweisung aber ansonsten verhält man sich da relativ frei auf,
und für uns ICE Cuber ist es halt in der Reha auch eine Durchgangsstation also es heißt wir warten quasi nur auf dem Weiterflug zum Südpol.
Und am Südpol die Station ist deutlich kleiner das ist tatsächlich auch nur eine Station der passenden im Sommer so 150 Leute ungefähr drauf.
150 Leute aus dem Sommer sind das schon 85 Gebäude gibt's da.
Anmeldung ja.
Ja du schon zurück gebisslos.
Genau das ist tatsächlich wieso eine kleine Stadt.
Dein Leben zu dauerhaft Menschen.
Jan Winter also McMurdo und am Südpol,
quasi um die Stationen am Laufen zu halten also am Südpol ist es so dass der wie gesagt im Sommer sind so um die 150 Leute und im Winter wird das reduziert auf ungefähr 40 und dann sozusagen die Gardinen Besatzungen also die sorgen dafür dass da alles am Leben halten wird da ist dann alles dabei das sind Ingenieure Wissenschaftler Mechaniker Ärzte,
Küche und so weiter das also die Sonne am Südpol geht im Endeffekt einmal im Jahr auf einmal mehr unter und im Winter ist es da dunkel.
Was hast du da 40 Leute die sind irgendwie mehrere Monate im Dunkeln was für ein Job.
Und ja machen machen alle freiwillig wir von Highschool wir haben auch zwei oder die den Winter verbringen sie sorgen dafür dass das Glück war sie weiterhin läuft.
Genau ja und hier die Leute aber die werden natürlich auch also ich war ja am Sommertag da und Winter müsste meine wirklich an ein Jahr bleiben und die den Winter da sind die wäre natürlich auch mit dem unglaublichen Ausblick belohnt also Polarlichter Sternenhimmel Milchstraße also,
wir sehen aber nur den ganzen Fotos die den das läuft das natürlich auch super faszinierend.
Verstehe okay ja das ist ein Feature aber das macht auch nicht ewig oder sowas.
Es gibt tatsächlich eine Person die habe ich aber nie persönlich kennengelernt der macht das glaube ich unter 13 Jahren das der jedes Jahr also,
wirklich tatsächlich dann immer nur ich weiß gar nicht im Sommer wahrscheinlich mal vom von der Antarktis runter aber ansonsten hätte ich den Winter auch durchgehen dort verbringt,
es gibt Leute finden es gut ich glaube ich könnte das auch nicht ein ganzes Jahr also die Preise für drei Wochen dreieinhalb Wochen die ich da war haben mir gereicht wann ein guter Eindruck.
Unterwasser hell.
Ja wie geht's dann weiter jetzt außer das jetzt weiter programmiert und weiter getestet wird gibt's schon also Ideen zum Ausbau für den ice cream gibt es.
Aber beschlossen ist doch gar nichts.
Nee beschlossen noch nichts außer würde natürlich weiß ich schon gearbeitet es gibt also auch bei uns um diese Leute die die Studien dazu machen also bevor sozusagen neues Experiment gebaut wird ist er steht der unter Mitarbeitern muss sozusagen erstmal,
blue skies am Ende sagen also warum ist das notwendig bei einem Größe einer größeren Version von Ice Cube wäre genau dieser Use-Case okay wollen Matrix bei noch höheren Energien,
messen der ist relativ klar das wollen wir gerne machen und dann musst du natürlich die Studien machen ok wie müssen so ein defekter aus wenn ja wie zahle ich ihm gesagt hat diese,
doppelter Abstand zwischen den Bohrlöchern das kommt aus solchen Studien heraus daran arbeiten Leute und dann zählt das rechtlich auch diese diese Forschungsanträge zu schreiben,
dass das ist wichtiger Arbeit aber nicht nur nicht nur im Prinzip nur eine neue Variante von Ice Cube die andere Variante ist das was du ihm auch angesprochen hast einfach,
Instrumentierung also diese Bohrlöcher noch enger beisammen zu machen um eben diese Auflösungsgrenze zu erhöhen,
daran wird gearbeitet Spezial auch durchaus mit dem Gedanken dass wir vielleicht versuchen wollen taunusring das dann auch zu finden.
Oder zumindest Nachweismethoden dazu zu verstehen aber es gibt auch ganz andere Techniken beispielsweise im Radiobereich also das was mit Eigelb machen ist ja ein blaues Licht Schränke auf Licht aber es gibt genauso die Möglichkeit Neutrinos beispielsweise über Radiowellen,
nachzuweisen das ist ein Tick komplizierter bei bei wie viel höheren Energien,
aber Radiowellen haben am Ende den Charme dass sie sozusagen nicht so schnell gestoppt werden können wir auch von unserem normalen Radio Funk das sozusagen Radiowelle auch ohne Probleme durch einbauen durchgeht liegt hingegen nicht.
Und da kann sich sozusagen im antarktischen Eis Radiowellen sehr viel länger sehr viel weiter ausbreiten und dann kann man eben noch größere Detektoren bauen.
Das heißt das Blaulicht das nicht die einzige der einzige Effekt sollen im Prinzip entsteht in dem Moment wo das Neutrino sich wandelt auch Radiowellen.
Genau können auch anstehender Bayern.
Können auch entstehen das weiß man das heißt ein bisschen money in Frechen Direktorin verbauen schauen kann man das noch mit rein versenken.
Genau richtig also das sind auch Ansätze dann doch durchaus Ansätze die Expertin schon bisschen verfolgt werden also,
von diesem Radioantennen gibt es gleich mittlerweile drei Stück am Südpol die bereits gebaut worden womit ein erster Test gemacht werden aber mit drei Stationen kann man noch nicht so wahnsinnig viel,
Musik machen das sind alles ist das wäre was sozusagen in den ganzen Garten vorher mit Eistee passiert ist mit den ersten Prototypen und Amanda das wird jetzt gerade aus dem bisschen im Radiobereich gemacht dass man die ersten Prototypen versenkt und guckt funktionieren die worauf muss man achten,
also ein ständiger Lernprozess.
Was ist da ja wahrscheinlich noch genug also man könnte jetzt an den konkreten Ort sich noch weiter ausdehnen sowohl nach unten als auch in die Breite.
Nach unten nicht aber in die Breite also nach unten ist der täglich nur noch ungefähr 200-300 m Platz dann kommt das Gestein.
Und ganz so tief nach unten wenn man auch nicht weil das ganze der ganze Südpol ist ein Gletscher der bewegt sich das heißt aller Wahrscheinlichkeit nach wird sich unten also ganz unten am Gletscher auf der Gesteinsschicht wird sich auch Wasser befinden also du kannst du tief immer noch nicht bohren.
Was ist soziale der Gletscher bewegt.
So sollte ein Ausbau würde dann sozusagen in den Namen ein wenig hinfällig machen oder mehr so ein Eis Quader Quader.
Ja oder das Wetter täglich ab wann sind noch viel größere Würfel also also die Idee heißt das eigentlich eisglut Generation 2.
Ja gut aber wenn man nicht weiter nach unten gehen kann und kann man ja.
Das ist dein gutes Recht klar.
Was ist das ausgewürfelt sozusagen ja Marcel aber noch irgendwas ganz wichtiges und nennenswertes vergessen ich habe gerade nicht so den Eindruck.
Ich glaube nicht also wie gesagt also es bleibt sehr spannend in allen Bereichen,
ob es jetzt gerade wieder zu uns wählen oder Neutrinos sind tatsächlich dieser dieser Multi-Messenger Gedanke dass man viele Dinge in verschiedenen Bereichen beobachtet das wird glaube ich nicht ganz spannende Sachen,
Jan und daneben das Highlight der Entdeckung der Neutrinos mit als Club angesprochen hast ich glaube dann wäre auch wenn das passiert so ein Highlight auch stärker in der Presse noch vertreten.
Auf jeden Fall schonmal jetzt bei Raumzeit wo es auch hingehört vielen vielen Dank für die Ausführung hier zum Icecube und den Neutrinos den unbekannten Wesen.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hierbei Raumzeit ich sag Tschüss bis bald.